la séance est ouverte mesdames et
messieurs les députés cher collègue
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement avant d'appeler l'examen
des questions au gouvernement
j'ai le triste de voir d'annoncer
officiellement la disparition de claude
goasguen qui vous le savez nous a
quittés le 28 mai dernier les mois que
cette nouvelle a suscité montre assez
l'estiment qu'en 25 ans de mandat
parlementaire
sans oublier son action de ministre de
la réforme de l'état
notre collègue avait conquis ge bien au
delà de sa famille politique
une vaste culture una liberté de ton
allié à une totale indépendance d'esprit
le goût du débat et la passion de la
politique
tel fut le député claude goasguen
mettant son savoir d'historiens du droit
au service de la représentation
nationale
sa verve nous manquera son acuité aussi
car si nous n'étions pas toujours
d'accord avec lui
tous ici nous le respections écoutions
après sa jeunesse militante est conservé
il a vite fait le choix de s'engager
dans la vie démocratique voyant qu'elle
seule pouvait donner des résultats en
politique
président du groupe d'amitié
france-israël
il s'est toujours mobilisés contre
l'antisémitisme député de paris claude
goasguen et est aussi une personnalité
influente dans la vie de la capitale
son dernier acte politique fut de voter
aux municipales dans ce 16e
arrondissement dont il avait été le
maire pendant plus de neuf années
il venait de fêter ses 75 ans quand le
qu'ovide 19 malheureusement
luffy chanceler parmi les dizaines de
milliers de français frappés par le
corps en un virus il connu les
souffrances infligées par cette pandémie
que nous nous efforçons de surmonter
pendant des semaines ce combattant
qu'était claude guasois elle lutta
contre la maladie il avait vaincu même
et se préparer à nous revenir mais il
était sorti si affaibli de l'épreuve que
le 28 mai son coeur c'est ça le battre à
sa famille à ses amis et à ses
collaborateurs
j'adresse en votre nom les condoléances
attristées de la représentation
nationale
je propose je prononcerai son éloge
funèbre
dès que notre assemblée pour assiéger au
complet en attendant je vous demande de
bien vouloir observée en mémoire de
notre collègue disparu
une minute de silence
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
la parole est à monsieur le président
damien abad le président monsieur le
premier ministre
aujourd'hui l'un de nos siège est vacant
notre hémicycle est orphelin orphelins
suite à la disparition de notre collègue
et ami claude goasguen habile débatteur
plein de panache et de force
claude ne laisser personne indifférent
il était un homme profondément libre
extrêmement cultivé qui parlait au et
qui parlait avec le coeur il aura
durablement marqué cet hémicycle
notamment pour son combat de chaque
instant contre l'antisémitisme
c'était surtout un homme droit et un
député qui faisait honneur à la
politique sa disparition tragique
après avoir lutté avec tant de force et
de courage comme vous le rappelez
monsieur le président nous rappelle
combien nous sommes vulnérables face à
une épidémie de cette ampleur et de
cette violence au nom de mon groupe est
républicain de chacun d'entre vous je
souhaite ici lui rendre hommage et
m'associer à la douleur de sa famille et
de ses proches
sur le premier ministre nous payons un
lourd tribut aux covic 19
tu auras endeuillé notre pays tout
entier qui aura endeuillé des milliers
de familles et qui endeuillent aussi
désormais notre hémicycle le décès de
près de 29000 français nous impose une
prise de conscience collective
nous devons être animés tous d'une
volonté sans faille pour dire plus
jamais ça
cela exige de nous de tirer les
enseignements de cette crise de
comprendre là où il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements
ce que nous devons changer pour ne pas
reproduire les mêmes erreurs du passé
nous le devons à toutes les victimes
mais aussi à tous les français n'ont
donc faire en sorte d'être parfaitement
préparer à l'avenir si par malheur un
nouveau risque de cette nature devait se
déclarer
et c'est d'ailleurs dans cette optique
que les députés les républicains ont été
à l'initiative du lancement dès demain
d'une commission d' enquête sur la
gestion de cette épidémie par les
pouvoirs publics sur le premier ministre
le parlement a pris ses responsabilités
avec cette commission denquête et ma
question est simple le gouvernement en
sont ils aussi prendre les siennes pour
tout simplement être au rendez-vous de
la transparence et de la vérité des
français merci monsieur le président la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
président à bad avant de vous répondre
permettez moi de m'associer à l'hommage
qui a été rendu par le président de
l'assemblée nationale et au la première
partie de votre question sur le décès de
votre collègue claude goasguen je
partage à la fois le souci que vous avez
de lui rendre hommage pour son parcours
pour son action pour sa personnalité et
monsieur le président à bad
reconnaissons le vous et moi qui le
connaissions quelle personnalité
quelle personnalité
truculente cultivés à la fois fine et
parfois brutales animé par une liberté
intellectuelle et une liberté de ton qui
je pense n'ont jamais été prise en
défaut
dévoué à ce qu'il croyait juste et au
combat politique qu'il entendait mener
il a impressionné à juste titre tous
ceux qui l'ont croisé il a été à
l'origine de vocation nationale ou
locale
et vous avez vous même utilisé le mot
panache je le reprendrais bien
volontiers car il en avait du panache et
d'une certaine façon un homme comme lui
qui aimait la bonne chère la culture le
débat passionné la confrontation des
idées qui aimait l'indépendance d'esprit
parfois l'indépendance d'esprit crâne
d'une certaine façon parce qu'il était
indépendant d'esprit
même quand il savait que je n'étais pas
forcément ni son intérêt disent on est
bien tout cela a composé un personnage
incroyablement français avec des
qualités éminentes peut-être aussi avec
des défauts qu'il reconnaissait
volontiers lui-même d'ailleurs mais un
personnage sympathique et et j'observe
monsieur le président à battre que sur
tous les bancs de cette assemblée y
compris parmi ceux qui ne partageaient
en rien ses choix politiques
beaucoup lui ont rendu hommage
reconnaissant chez lui
quelqu'un qui s'était engagé et qui
défend des ses idées et au fond dans cet
hémicycle
quels que soient les choix politiques
des uns et des autres c'est probablement
le plus bel hommage qu'on puisse rendre
de dire voilà quelqu'un qui s'est tenu
debout et qui a défendu ses idées alors
je veux m'associer à ce que vous avez
dit monsieur le président rabat
quant à la deuxième partie de votre
question celle qui après avoir indiqué
que le parlement avait pris et prendrait
ses responsabilités
interrogé le gouvernement sur sa volonté
de prendre ses responsabilités je vous
dirais très tranquillement monsieur abad
bien entendu il ne me paraît pas
monsieur à battre que depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire le gouvernement
n'ait pas voulu assumer ses
responsabilités ni les mauvaises
nouvelles
et il y en a eu ni les difficultés et il
y en a eu ni même parfois les bonnes
nouvelles il y en a eu et j'espère qu'il
continuera à en avoir mais donc vous
trouverez toujours le gouvernement
monsieur aba'a de monsieur le président
prêt à répondre aux questions qui se
posent en ne faisant jamais dans la
simplicité mais en essayant d'expliquer
la situation telle que nous l'avons vécu
tel que nous dès que nous avons fait
face collectivement en ne voulant rien
exonérés mais en regardant aussi
peut-être comment nos amis partenaires
étrangers ont vécu la même situation où
une situation approchante et en
regardant comment eux aussi avaient fait
face en s'interrogeant sur les
conditions qui étaient les nôtres au
moment du démarrage de cette crise et
les décisions qui ont été prises je suis
parfaitement prêt
monsieur le président et je ne vous
cache pas que je préfère répondre
précisément à toutes ces questions
plutôt qu'à avoir comme ce fut le cas
parfois ingéré des explosions d'angoise
où des explosions de colère et parfois
ça n'ait pas été votre cas monsieur le
président ne le prenez pas en mauvaise
passe mais parfois des explosions de
mauvaise foi et donc vous nous demandez
la transparence nous l'avons donné dès
le début vous nous demandez la
responsabilité nous l'avons donné dès le
début nous continuerons merci monsieur
la parole est à madame marie noëlle
battistel merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre depuis
plusieurs semaines gynécologue
obstétricien au conseil pour l'égalité
femmes/hommes planning familial ou
encore parlementaires de tous bords se
mobilisent pour alerter sur les
difficultés rencontrées par de
nombreuses femmes en matière d'accès à
l'ivg et j'ai pendant le confinement
afin d'éviter la contamination de leur
équipe les plannings familiaux ont été
obligées de fermer leurs portes et de
fonctionner sur la base d'un service
minimum
s'efforçant de répondre au mieux aux
demandes des femmes plus encore la
plupart des hôpitaux observe quant à eux
une baisse d'activité en matière dit vg
par ailleurs le planning familial note
lui une augmentation de 100 84 % des
demandes diverger hors délai il ne fait
pas donc pas de doute que le confinement
à des effets délétères qui se
ressentiront encore plusieurs semaines
vous avez instauré un numéro vert
faciliter la téléconsultation ou encore
étendu le délai de réalisation des ivg
médicamenteuses hors milieu hospitalier
je m'en réjouis mais cela demeure
évidemment insuffisant il est
indispensable que chaque femme puisse
disposer d'une solution adaptée à sa
situation personnelle les vg
médicamenteuse est une réponse mais ce
ne saurait constituer à elle scelle la
solution nous avons proposé à plusieurs
reprises que pendant la durée de l'état
d'urgence et jusqu'à trois mois après sa
cessation libéré puis cette pratique est
au minimum jusqu'à la fin de la 14e
semaine de grossesse
cette mesure porte et à titre
exceptionnel répondants respect du droit
à l'image est déjà très inégale en
période ordinaire s'est pourtant
toujours heurtée à un refus du
gouvernement monsieur le premier
ministre
allez vous enfin permettre cette mesure
répondant à la détresse qui s'exprime et
éviter que la crise sanitaire n'entraîne
un recul du droit des femmes durement
acquis je vous remercie
merci madame la députée
la parole est à monsieur adrien takeshi
grether état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
madame la députée il n'est pas question
cette période de confinement puisse
conduire à un recul des droits des
femmes et vous le savez cette épidémie
depuis 19 a mis en tension notre système
de santé il nous a contraints à des
programmes et de nombreuses activités
hospitalières et le cas échéant à
reporter un certain nombre de soins non
urgents
dans ce contexte nous avons craint vous
avez craint un certain nombre
d'associations le planning familial
les professionnels ont craint que des
difficultés d'accès à l'avortement et
courez à l'assemblée nationale comme au
sénat des parlementaires se sont fait
l'écho de ces difficultés comme vous
venez de le faire en réponse le
gouvernement a agi très rapidement le
ministère de la santé évidemment la
secrétaire d'état à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et de façon
dérogatoire pendant l'état d'urgence
sanitaire nous avons adopté un certain
nombre de mesures vous en avez rappelé
quelques-unes nous avons permis
effectivement la réalisation de
l'ensemble des consultations
obligatoires par télémédecine pardon et
y compris la consultation de prise de
pilule contraceptive pour garantir le
secret avortement pour jeunes filles
mineures nous avons modifié les
attestations de déplacement période de
confinement pour davantage simplifier
les démarches encore le mystère des
mises des solidarités de la santé a
demandé à la haute autorité de santé
si nous pouvions allonger la période
durant laquelle il était possible de
réaliser un avortement médicamenteux
hors hôpital et le 10 avril dernier vous
le savez la haute autorité de santé a
rendu un avis favorable pour permettre
l'utilisation de la pilule abortive
jusqu'à la neuvième semaine d'aménorrhée
alors ce que c'était cette semaine en
temps normal et le 14 avril nous avons
pris un arrêté allonger le délai des
avortements médicamenteux
nous entendons que certains dans vos
rangs notamment au sénat ont souhaité
dans le cadre de l'examen du projet de
loi d'yves et portant diverses
dispositions urgentes que d'aller plus
loin d'un père de cris j'ai allongé le
délai de libérer mais cela a été dit et
je vous le redis ici le gouvernement et
daf défavorable à une telle disposition
et que ça soit porté dans le ce cadre là
c'est un débat plus large plus global
qui doit être menée depuis le 11 mai un
certain nombre d'activités par ailleurs
hospitalière se sont remises en route
fort heureusement et en ce qui concerne
l'état d'urgence sanitaire des
dispositifs des enclumes air sinistre
ficultés madame la députée oui monsieur
le ministre
évidemment votre réponse ne me satisfait
absolument pas je conduis une mission
avec ma collègue cécile mus cotis sur
l'axé ali belgique est déjà très inégale
en france là on ne fait qu'accentuer les
inégalités votre réseau la parole et
aval à bénédicte taurine
je vous remercie ma question s'adresse à
monsieur ministre de l'économie
la compagnie aérienne ryanair menace de
licencier des pilotes et personnels
navigants en france à moins qu'il ne
consente à baisser leur rémunération
pendant cinq ans derichebourg
aéronautique services sous traitant
d'airbus et dassault envisage un plan
social qui se traduirait par 700
suppressions de postes
ce nombre pourrait être revue à la
baisse si les salariés renoncent et
entre autres à leur 13e - c'est dans ce
contexte que libération dévoile le fait
que le patron de la compagnie aérienne
klm air france klm pardon va toucher 1,6
million d'euros de bonus pour l'année
2019 le ministre des finances
néerlandais a lui indiqué que son
gouvernement a voté contre ce bonus et a
justifié cela par l'attribution des deux
financés par les contribuables pour le
gouvernement français a en revanche
c'est un peu différent
en effet votre cabinet considère que
c'est un droit acquis pour une
performance passée et qui n'a donc pas
vocation à être remises en cause
aujourd'hui
le gouvernement l'a validé le 26 mai
dernier en fait que 8,19 l'abandon
c'est toujours aux mêmes que vous
demander de faire des efforts pour un
grand patron quel que soit le contexte
il va conserver ses acquis les salariés
eux doivent y renoncer
madame pénicaud dans les médias fait
appel aux entreprises pour se serrer les
coudes et signé des accords de
performance collective mis en place par
les ordonnances travail en 2017 indique
que ce dispositif serait une alternative
aux licenciements et aux plans sociaux
en quoi cela consiste en réalité en fait
ça impose aux salariés de faire des
efforts d'accepter une baisse de salaire
s'il ne souhaite pas le faire si je se
bat avec les syndicats pour refuser ce
chantage il se voit accusé d'avoir été
responsable
la fermeture de leur entreprise au
moment où les associations nous
indiquent une hausse de la pauvreté en
france que les gens sont dans la
précarité alimentaire et que cela va
s'accentuer dans les mois à venir au
moment la rémunération des patrons du
cac 40 atteint en moyenne de 177 fois le
smic et que la rémunération de ses
dirigeants est trois fois plus rapide
que celle des salariés
monsieur le ministre quelles
alternatives proposées vous à la
majorité des françaises et des français
à part de travailler plus pour gagner
merci madame la députée la parole et à
monsieur bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie et des finances sur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée la seule
alternative que nous proposons
aujourd'hui c'est celle de l'emploi
l'emploi face à une montée des
licenciements face à une multiplication
des faillites dont on voit qu'elles
menacent tous les territoires en france
cet emploi avec les décisions qui ont
été prises par le premier ministre et
par le président de la république nous
l'avons sauver et de l'avs ont sauvés
grâce au chômage partiel en permettant à
des millions de français plutôt que de
perdre leur emploi d'avoir leur salaire
pris en charge par l'état à hauteur de
100% jusqu'à 4 smic
c'est la première fois que nous avons eu
un dispositif de protection des salariés
et de protection des emplois aussi
généreux nous avons décidé avec le
prémunit se faire évoluer ce dispositif
en demandant aux entrepreneurs de faire
une part de l'effort parce que
l'activité reprend donc indemnisation ne
sera plus de 100 % le prise en charge
par l'état
mais 2 85% 15.2 reste à charge pour les
entrepreneurs
mais pour faire quoi justement pour
garder des moyens financiers pour
soutenir les entreprises qui sont les
plus fragiles pour continuer à aider
ceux qui sont en difficulté pour
alimenter le fonds de solidarité pour
les commerçants les indépendants des
restaurateurs tous ceux qui vont
continuer à rester ferme et nous allons
continuer à faire évoluer le dispositif
de soutien massif à l'économie française
avec une préoccupation principale
préserver l'emploi en france
offrir des perspectives sont sans
question de baisser ici ou là les
rémunérations des uns ou des autres mais
avec l'obsession qu'il y ait de l'emploi
pour tous dans notre pays merci monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à monsieur le président
philippe vigier ce premier ministre où
l'avez vous même souligné en annonçant
la seconde phase du déconfinement la
situation sanitaire s'est fortement
améliorée même sur les plans près de
30000 morts et j'ai une pensée pour
notre collègue claude goasguen il nous
faut désormais continuer d'apporter des
réponses concrètes puissante à la
hauteur des conséquences désastreuses
que va continuer à les produire cette
crise et penser dès aujourd'hui la
troisième établi des ponts finement je
pense aux conséquences économiques en
particulier pour les secteurs de tenri
des bars des restaurants du tourisme
nous savons tous qu avec les mesures de
distanciation sociale qui existe de très
nombreuses entreprises ne pourront pas
survivre
claudon vous poser trois questions
précises à quelle échéance
envisagez-vous une reprise de ses
activités dans les conditions normales
ensuite allez vous mettre en place des
aides ciblées des exonérations de
charges pour les bars les restaurants de
manière à accompagner ces entreprises
dans cette phase transitoire
enfin alors que l'interdiction des
circulaires a été levée partout en
france allez vous supprimez ce décret
qui limite de manière incompréhensible
le transport aérien entre la corse et le
continent
mettant à mal l'économie corse voudrais
ensuite monsieur le premier ministre
vous parler des conséquences sociales de
cette crise et plus particulièrement de
l'école vous avez fait le choix devrait
progressivement les écoles sur la base
du volontariat afin de ne pas abandonner
les enfants des familles les plus
fragiles
si cette décision pouvait se comprendre
elle n'est aujourd'hui plus tenable tout
d'abord parce que sur le terrain on
constate ce sont souvent les élèves les
plus en difficulté qui sont restés
éloignés de l'école ensuite parce qu'il
est inconcevable que la rentrée puisse
s'effectuer dans ces conditions que ce
soit pour les classes ou pour les
transports scolaires donc mes questions
seront simples quels seront les
principes d'organisation de la rentrée
scolaire et quelles mesures de soutien
envisagées vous pour les enfants qui
malheureusement plus pâti de ces mesures
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
président vigier vous poser beaucoup de
questions elles sont bonnes je les
comprends parfaitement
vous assistez d'abord sur l'hôtellerie
les cafés les restaurants sur ce secteur
qui est particulièrement impacté par la
crise sanitaire que nous venons de
traverser puisqu'il a été s'agissant des
cafés et des restaurants interdit
d'exercer pendant de longues semaines
s'agissant de l'hôtellerie il a été n'a
pas été formellement interdite enfin par
définition dès lors qu'il n'y avait pas
de restauration est potes déplacement
c'était compliqué de faire fonctionner
ces établissements on a donc dans ces
secteurs là dans ce secteur là payé un
très lourd tribut à la crise sanitaire
et même si des mesures puissante
vous le savez elles ont d'ailleurs été
saluée comme telle par les représentants
de la profession ont été prises pour
permettre à l'ensemble des acteurs de ce
secteur de passer cette étape les
conditions de la reprise sont à certains
égards à certains égards presque plus
inquiétante pour les représentants de la
profession et pour la profession dans
son ensemble parce que lorsque votre
loyer est d'un niveau tel que
l'organisation de votre activité avec
moitié moins de couverts
vous rendre la tâche quasi impossible
pour arriver à votre point mort voire
pour commencer à gagner des sous vous
savez que vous allez avoir un problème
au redémarrage
je veux dire plusieurs choses sur ce
sujet monsieur le président vigier
d'abord nous avons pris des mesures pour
permettre aux acteurs de passer l'étape
et nous avons indiqué le ministre de
l'économie et des finances le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères tous les membres
du gouvernement tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'avenir de ce secteur
ont dit que ces mesures avaient vocation
à durer jusqu'à la fin de l'année nous
voulons continuer à aider ce secteur
pour qu'ils puissent passer cette étape
très difficile
d'abord parce que c'est parfaitement
légitime ensuite parce que c'est une
force de notre pays
c'est un des éléments de l'attractivité
de notre pays c'est un des éléments si
j'ose dire de la façon de vivre
collective qui est la nôtre et à
laquelle nous sommes extrêmement
attachés
il faut donc que nous les aidions ces
mesures nous l'avons dit vont se
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin de l'année
puisque ces secteurs sont encore impacté
par la deuxième chose nous avons procédé
un déconfinement progressif c'est vrai
je l'assumé pour des raisons sanitaires
dans les départements verts qui sont
l'immense majorité des départements
français on peut désormais fonctionner
avec des règles sanitaires qui sont
évidemment beaucoup plus lourde que
celle qui prévalait avant le confinement
mais on peut fonctionner et on peut
recommencer à fonctionner et je crois
que chacun fait l'expérience aujourd'hui
de du plaisir évident qu'il peut y avoir
à retrouver les cafés et les restaurants
le moment venu dans les zone dite orange
pour l'essentiel dans l'île de france à
mayotte et en guyane les règles de
fonctionnement de ces services ne sont
pas encore
aussi favorables que celles qui
prévalent dans les départements vers
parce que il y a un peu plus de virus
circulant dans ces territoires et que
nous voulons limiter au maximum les
risques pour des raisons que chacun peut
parfaitement comprendre je crois ici
quand est ce que les conditions seront
redevenues normales vont poser une
question monsieur le président à
laquelle je peux difficilement répondre
je peux indiquer ceci que nous avons
toujours procédé par étapes de trois
semaines et que donc si tout se passe
bien ce que nous espérons ce que le
passé récent nous laisse espérer alors
le 21 juin le 22 juin on pourra
peut-être je l'espère dans les zones
oranges recommencé à fonctionner comme
aujourd'hui on fonctionne dans les zones
vertes
ce sera déjà une avancée majeure
quand pourrons nous abaisser les règles
d'exploitation sanitaires qui ont été
imposées je ne le sais pas encore
exactement monsieur le président vigier
parce que je ne veux pas je ne veux pas
nous placer collectivement dans une
situation où l'épidémie pourrait
repartir avant que nous ne la voyons
et donc nous allons probablement
commencer l'été avec des règles
sanitaires en effet plus stricte que
celle qui prévalait avant le confinement
l'objectif
encore une fois c'est d'accompagner ces
secteurs à franchir cette étape leur
redonner leur attractivité vous avez
posé une question sur la corse et sur
une une rédaction d'un décret qui
miroite entre les transports maritimes
les transports aériens vous avez
parfaitement raison de le faire
le décret sera corrigé dans le bon sens
dès ce soir
enfin s'agissant de l'école s'agissant
de l'école la question est délicate et
plus exactement elle est grave parce que
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire plusieurs
fois je le crois profondément de tous
les défis et de toutes les parfois j'ai
utilisé le terme bombe à retardement je
suis pas sûr que ce soit le meilleur
terme enfin néanmoins je les utilise et
donc je vais l'assumer
qu'ils nous laissent qui nous sont
laissées par cette crise sanitaire la
bombe à retardement pédagogique n'est
pas la moins importante
elle n'est pas la moins dangereuse le la
déconnexion complète le décrochage d'une
certaine façon l'absence de lien réel
entre
un très grand nombre de l'enfant de
collégiens de lycéens avec l'école aura
un coût d'un coût humain un coût
pédagogique un coup intellectuelle un
coût social et c'est évident ce que nous
essayons de faire et je dis nous
essayons avec beaucoup de modestie et
d'humilité
c'est d'encourager très vivement et je
crois que dans beaucoup de cas les
professeurs le fond d'encourager très
vivement les professeurs à identifier ce
qui dans telle ou telle classe ont le
plus besoin et ça n'est pas forcément ce
n'est pas forcément une question sociale
ça doit toujours être d'abord une
priorité pédagogique dans n'importe
quelle classe on peut identifier des
enfants qui vont avoir plus de problèmes
si ce lien physique avec l'école n'est
pas rétablie rapidement que d'autres
ça veut pas dire que les autres sont pas
importants bien entendu mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut essayer dans un moment
de crise de s'attacher aux priorités la
priorité pédagogique elle est bien là me
semble-t-il
il faudra ensuite qu'avec l'évolution de
la crise nous puis sur desserrer l'étau
des conditions sanitaires d'accueil dans
les écoles le faire sans risque bien
entendu mais le faire progressivement de
façon à pouvoir permettre le retour d'un
plus grand nombre d'enfants dans les
écoles
et enfin il ya une troisième raison je
l'aï dit ici à l'assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière et je veux leur dire
aujourd'hui avec beaucoup de clarté dans
la façon de reprendre la classe dans la
façon de d'accueillir à nouveau les
élèves il faut et ce n'est pas un
scandale c'est même parfaitement
légitime il faut s'interroger sur le
caractère pratique pour les parents
proposer des demi journées d'accueil à
l'école même des journées alternée c'est
d'une certaine façon placer les parents
et leurs employeurs dans des situations
qui sont parfois quasi impossible à
gérer
et même si l'impératif et pédagogique et
il doit rester pédagogique bien entendu
il me paraît que on peut dans les
circonstances que nous connaissons
prendre en compte cet impératif prendre
en compte cette nécessité qui est une
nécessité d'intérêt général pour essayer
de faire en sorte que l'accueil des
enfants répondent aussi aussi à cette
logique la préparation de la rentrée
sera une grande affaire la préparation
de la rentrée de septembre sera une
grande affaire le mois de juin est
engagé mais l'arrêt pas la préparation
de la rentrée de septembre sera une
grande affaire
elle fera l'objet d'un travail intensif
par le ministère avec je l'espère les
élus locaux qui sont évidemment
intéressé par les questions que nous
aurons à arbitrer mais je crois que nous
souhaitons tous que la rentrée puisse se
passer dans les meilleures conditions
sanitaires pédagogique possible mais
nous avons encore d'ici là beaucoup de
travail merci monsieur le premier
ministre la parole et à monsieur thierry
benoit merci monsieur le président
permettez moi de saluer avant toute
chose au nom des députés du groupe u10
la mémoire de claude goasguen et
d'adresser des pensées affectueuses à sa
famille et aux collègues députés du
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur leproux
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
ministre de la fonction publique avec
les collègues députés udi du groupe udi
nous souhaitons partager avec vous un
sujet de préoccupation les crises
quelles qu'elles soient et la crise que
nous vivons n'y échappe pas elles ont
tendance à amplifier nos faiblesses et
nos failles et ce sont souvent les plus
fragiles d'entre 8 d'entre nous qui en
paient le plus lourd tribut
et je ne voudrions attirer l'attention
du gouvernement même si on sait qu'il
est préoccupé par ce sujet sur la
question de l'accès aux services publics
pour une part de nos concitoyens je veux
parler de celles et ceux qui ont besoin
d'accéder de contacter facilement pour
l'emploi les services de la caisse
d'allocations familiales de l'assurance
maladie
les services des impôts même les
services de justice et à l'heure du
télétravail à l'heure de la
distanciation physique
je suis convaincu que les français et
notamment les plus fragiles d'entre nous
ont le plus grand besoin d'un
rapprochement et de liens humains et
monsieur le premier ministre je vous ai
écouté attentivement comme à chaque
séance des questions au gouvernement
et j'apprécie la manière dont vous
développez le plan de déconfinement mais
je souhaiterais que le gouvernement
puisse nous exposer les mesures qu'il
compte mettre en oeuvre pour que les
services publics en france
au gré des diverses réformes et bien
qu'il y ait un lien très fort très
puissant entre les concitoyens et les
services publics
parce que ça me paraît être essentiel de
faciliter la vie de nos concitoyens
la compréhension et accélérer les
démarches administratives en quelqu'un
sur mer s'est agitée avec la parole et à
monsieur olivier du secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
benoist permettez moi de profiter de
votre question pour saluer l'engagement
des agents publics des trois versants de
la fonction publique territoriale
hospitalière bien sûr fonction publique
d'état qui tout au long de la période de
confinement ou garanties dans le cadre
des plans de continuité d'activité
l'accès à un service public minimal sur
tout le territoire avec votre question
vous appeler l'attention du gouvernement
sur les difficultés que pourrait
rencontrer certains de nos concitoyens
si dans le cadre de la reprise
nous privilégierons uniquement l'accès
par le numérique l'accès par des
services dématérialisés
ça n'est pas l'option du gouvernement
nous voulons privilégier le télétravail
pour éviter qu'il y ait trop de monde
sur des sites avec une proximité trop
importante mais nous voulons qu'il y ait
du présentiel par des mots pardonnez moi
ce barbarisme et progressivement nous
avons de plus en plus d'agents sur
l'ensemble des sites
nous développons des accueils par
téléphone beaucoup plus facile d'accès
qu'un accueil numérique ou internet
nous développons des prises de
rendez-vous et nous on sorte aussi
d'adapter un certain nombre de
procédures
c'est ce qui nous a amenés avec gérald
darmanin à décaler la date de fin de la
campagne de déclaration des revenus au
12 juin pour permettre à celles et ceux
qui font une déclaration papier d'avoir
plus de temps pour se rendre dans les
points de contact de la direction
générale des finances publiques est
derrière votre question il y a
évidemment la situation de reprise
d'activité nous connaissons il y à aussi
l'accès aux services publics
à plus long terme et votre question vos
remarques et vos interrogations que nous
partageons m'amène à souligner deux
points ou en tout cas de chantiers que
nous gagnons à approfondir le premier
chantier c'est celui des maisons france
services mais ils ont déjà été labellisé
sous l'égide de jacqueline gourault
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
me lot que le seront d'ici 2022 pour
permettre la mutualisation et un accès
partagé à l'ensemble des opérateurs vous
avez cités et puis il ya une deuxième
orientation qui est celle du
gouvernement que nous devons approfondir
c'est l'arrêté sous l'autorité du
premier ministre lors du ctp le comité
de la transformation public du 19
novembre 2019
lorsque nous avons acté le fait qu'il
fallait déconcentrés des services rue
réinstaller pardonnez-moi des agents sur
tout le territoire en considérant que
l'échelon départemental était un bon
échelon de proximité que l'état devait
réinvestir les territoires c'est second
sacré monsieur le ministre monsieur le
premier ministre le ministre de la santé
a annoncé hier un assouplissement
supplémentaire du confinement dans les
ehpad avec la possibilité pour les
proches de venir visiter les résidents
manière un peu plus souple un peu plus
large
il était temps à l'heure où les cafés et
restaurants peuvent rouvrir il aurait
été en effet totalement injuste de
maintenir intangible des règles très
draconiennes de confinement dans les
ehpad nous nous réjouissons nous les
républicains de cette annonce de
nouvelles possibilités de visites dans
les épargnes les réclamions ainsi que de
nombreuses associations à commencer par
l'association des directeurs des pales
et nous avons craint très franchement un
moment que les ehpad ne soient les
grands oubliés de la phase 2 du
déconfinement comme il l'avait été lors
du confinement dans une question
d'actualité du 21 avril j'avais déjà
interpeller le gouvernement et insisté
sur le fait que l' isolement
la solitude la privation des contacts
avec les proches la tristesse pouvaient
être des poisons mortels
il n'était donc que temps c'est une
question de dignité la dignité que nous
devons à nos anciens faut-il rappeler
monsieur le premier ministre que la
situation dans les ehpad a été une
source constante de préoccupation pour
nos concitoyens nous avons nous les
répliques un régulièrement interpellé le
gouvernement sur le manque de test le
manque de masquer le manque de tenue de
protection
le manque de personnel les chiffres des
décès dans les ehpad dans notre pays
sont très élevé et rien que pour les
villes de ma circonscription pour
département des hauts-de-seine ces
chiffres sont absolument tragique
pouvez-vous détailler à la
représentation nationale et donc à
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
les mesures d'assouplissement qui ont
été annoncés hier et qui sont censées
entrer en vigueur à compter du vendredi
5 juin tout le monde ne lit pas les
communiquer presse publié sur le site du
ministère de la santé
y aura-t-il un protocole sanitaire
précis et quand ce protocole sanitaire
sera-t-il envoyé aux directeurs
d'établissements je vois merci merci
chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la cense merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame là la
députée constance le grip il n'est pas
de règles draconiennes particulière il
n'est que des règles qui visent à
protéger la santé de nos concitoyens et
c'est ce qui nous a animés depuis le
début de cette crise évidemment
concernant les ehpad comme toutes les
autres populations et c'est ce qui nous
anime ans encore et je vais répondre
précisément à votre question car je ne
vous apprends rien les personnes âgées
constituent un public plus vulnérables
les faits sont là plus de 70% des
personnes décédées nos concitoyens
décédé dans notre pays ont plus de 75
ombre vous l'avez rappelé depuis le
début je me paye le préciser depuis le
début de la crise nous avons mis en
place un certain nombre de dispositifs
en direction des ehpad pour ne pas
laisser les ehpad seul dans la décision
médicale et dans le soin avec notamment
la mise en place de permanences de
spécialiste de gériatrie nous avons
déployé des renforts de personnel
beaucoup de professionnels qu'il faut
saluer ici se sont mobilisés manifester
nous a fait nous avons fait en sorte
qu'ils puissent venir en soutien des
professionnels dans les ehpad et puis
vous le savez nous avons décidé de
verser une prime exceptionnelle d'au
moins 1000 euros pour l'ensemble des
professionnels qui ont été confrontées à
la crise sanitaire et ceux financés par
l'assurance maladie quel que soit le
statut d établissement
enfin vous le savez une enveloppe de 475
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaire a été versée aux ehpad
pour leur permettre de faire face au
surcoût de la crise vous évoquiez
l'était sachez que a aujourd'hui depuis
le 7 avril trois cent mille tests ont
été réalisés dans les ehpad et puis vous
l'avez dit le ministre a annoncé un
assouplissement des règles alors cela
reste évidemment sous le contrôle des
directeurs d'établissement c'est à eux
de me mettre c'est à eux de mettre
monsieur le président abbas va y venir
de mettre en place les conditions
nécessaires il ya encore près de 45 %
des établissements aujourd'hui qui
signale encore un cas de co vide vous
voyez donc qu'il est important de
préserver une approche sanitaires très
strictes mais oui
à partir du 5 juin vendredi prochain
plus les visites pourront s'effectuer à
plus de deux personnes et les mineurs
notamment les enfants pour venir voir
leurs grands parents leurs grands
parents et a donné aux cheveux bruns
mouche monsieur le président permettez
moi ou non de mon groupe modem et
apparentés de saluer la mémoire de
claude goasguen son engagement sa
constance et son combat opiniâtre contre
notamment tous les anti sémitisme ceux
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui est une pensée à
ses proches à sa famille à sa famille
politique
ma question concerne les attributions
pour la moselle des crédits destinés à
la couverture des surcoûts relatifs à la
prise en charge de la colite 19
j'y associe l'ensemble des
parlementaires mosellans de la majorité
à ce jour notre région grand-est compte
20% des décès qu'ovide de france face à
ce cataclysme les soignants en tenue
portant haut l'étendard du soin et de
ses valeurs engager pleinement dans leur
mission en conscience agissante
pourtant en moselle les premiers crédits
versés ne sont pas à la hauteur des
frais engagés et du nombre de patients
touchés et soigné par l'aco vite il
laisse à penser que notre département a
subi des arbitrages défavorables au
profit de ses voisins pour un caisse un
coût estimé à 6,3 milliards d'euros 6,3
millions pardon d'euros le chr de
metz-thionville a ainsi reçu seulement
2,3 millions soit quatre fois moins de
crédits que les hôpitaux universitaires
de strasbourg deux fois moins que ceux
du chu de nancy
et ce alors qu'il a été au moins autant
touché que ses voisins par la crise
sanitaire et la remarque vaut aussi pour
les autres centres hospitaliers publics
et privés du département les ch de
sarreguemines forbach sarrebourg pour
l'hôpital d'instruction des armées les
hôpitaux privés de metz robert schuman
clinique claude-bernard la clinique
saint nabor sos santé à saint-avold le
quai membres'' paris notre dame à
thionville satellise avait pas eu de
saint maurice à moyeuvre saint-françois
marange silvange tous ces acteurs ont
permis de tripler en moins de deux
semaines les capacités de rémy nation
durant la crise et l'accueil encore
thing et dans les nécessaires au pic de
l'épidémie 32 % des mallettes qu'ovide
en réanimation étaient pris en charge
dans
les hôpitaux privés de moselle pour
garder intacte cette chaîne de
solidarité monsieur le ministre
enrichissez là car s'il nous faut
constamment travailler élever les
esprits verte doit s'affirmer avec force
et vigueur la parole est à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
un mouche vous tous nous savons
l'engagement l'implication qui a été
celui des professionnels de santé dans
le grand est
première région touchée par le cos vide
et à leur suite de l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé et vous l'avez
dit cela transparaît au travers de vos
propos
rien ne sera plus comme avant pour notre
système de santé dans et déjà avec ma
santé 2022 qui avait fait l'objet de
discussions ici nous avions fait ce
diagnostic nous avions pris les bonnes
orientations mais le ministre olivier
ferrand l'a dit clairement nous n'avions
pas été assez loin
nous n'allions pas assez fort et c'est
donc tout le sens de la grande
concertation qu'il a lancé la semaine
dernière avec le premier ministre est en
première ligne face à la vague
les soignants ont fait face et parfois
payé un lourd tribut alors dans votre
question vous abordez un point
particulier qui est celui de la
compensation financière de la crise et
puis plus spécifiquement encore celui de
la situation des établissements de votre
département la moselle
vous le savez monsieur le député une
première enveloppe nationale de 377
millions d'euros a été allouée en avril
aux établissements de santé pour
compenser les surcoûts liés à la prise
en charge des patients que vider cette
enveloppe a été calculé sur la base des
données d'activité du mois de mars et
qui explique les allocations que vous
évoquiez mais une seconde enveloppe sera
allouée prochainement aux établissements
cette enveloppe est de 100 millions
d'euros
elle viendra compléter renforcer les
dotations allouées pour les territoires
qui ont été les plus touchées par l'aco
vide
évidemment le grand est évidemment l'île
de france et ce pour tous les secteurs
de spécialisation qu'ils soient publics
ou privés
je rappelle aussi qu'une garantie de
financement été mise en place depuis
mars pour tous les établissements de
santé pour sécuriser leur trésorerie et
leurs recettes d'activité qui ont pu
être en baisse cette solidarité que vous
saluer doit évidemment être récompensés
au plus juste au plus près et c'est tout
le sens des mesures que nous avons
prises et que nous allons prendre encore
dans les semaines qui viennent
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
madame marine brunier merci monsieur le
président avant de poser ma question
permettez moi mon tour de rendre hommage
à notre collègue claude goasguen et
d'avoir une pensée pour ses proches
monsieur le ministre le monde médical
s'inquiète de la pénurie des cures arrêt
des produits utilisés pour l'anesthésié
nous avons été alertés par les
commissions médicales des cliniques et
hôpitaux sur les conséquences délétères
de ses manques
nous savons que la pénurie est mondiale
mais après les difficultés
d'approvisionnement en masquer
protection qu'on pensait souvent par les
collectivités territoriales
qu'allons-nous faire face à ce nouveau
danger nous comprenons que l'état tente
d'anticiper une deuxième vague mais que
fait-on des interventions médicales des
programmes et de ses patients qui ne
savent pas quand ils pourront enfin être
opérée depuis des semaines vous parlez
des risques du renoncement soins mais
monsieur le ministre que faire quand les
produits nécessaires aux opérations sont
réquisitionnés par l'état les agences
régionales de santé répète sans cesse
qu'elles attendent les consignes du
gouvernement pour distribuer les
produits mais il est urgent d'intervenir
quand allons-nous enfin retrouvé notre
souveraineté de médicamenteuse
car si nous saluons l'initiative du
ségur de la santé
les annonces pour le moment ne concerne
que l'hôpital c'est bien mais c'est peu
c'est tout notre système de santé
celui qui était censé être le plus
performant au monde qu'il faut revoir
faisons preuve d'humilité et ayons
confiance en nos soignants qui ont tenu
et tiennent toujours
malgré le manque de moyens et de
considération monsieur le ministre
la complémentarité des municipalités et
des collectivités a été prouvée là où
l'état n'a pas eu les moyens d'agir
certaines ont d'ailleurs réussi à
impliquer les laboratoires les cliniques
les hôpitaux dont le dépistage massif de
la population et parfois même
gratuitement
car oui monsieur le ministre pour
endiguer l'épidémie la prévention évite
souvent l'intervention mais pour ce qui
est de l'approvisionnement des
médicaments des médicaments cela ne peut
relever que de l'état monsieur le
ministre quelles réponses allez vous
apporter aux soignants et patients
concernant la pénurie des cures arrêt
anesthésiant merci va débuter la parole
à monsieur le secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre des solidarités et de la
santé ainsi monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée je vais vous répondre je vais
vous dire ce que nous avons fait et ce
que nous allons faire car vous avez
raison l'explosion partout dans le monde
comme vous l'avez souliers parfois plus
de 2000 % de nombreux médicaments
nécessaires pour la prise en charge des
patients pour intervention chirurgicale
sinon vous êtes désagréable à chaque
fois un grès crée des tensions pour tous
qui approvisionnements et les capacités
de production en france comme ailleurs
alors depuis le début nous avons nous
sommes mobilisés sur cette question nous
allons mener plusieurs actions la
première c'est le ministre le ministre
de la solidarité de la santé monsieur le
député qui a mené qui a mis en place une
gestion rigoureuse des médicaments
disponibles en faisant remonter les
stocks des hôpitaux et des cliniques
privées vers les établissements en
tension avec le président de la
république avec le premier ministre le
ministre de la santé toujours lui
monsieur le député a personnellement
contacté les laboratoires qui
fournissent des médicaments pour nous
assurer que la france bénéficie
rapidement d'un réapprovisionnement
nous avons à cet égard d'opter nouvelle
stratégie en achetant des produits les
plus critiques au niveau national afin
de sécuriser pour les industriels
d'importants volumes qui leur permettent
de produire
nous avons enfin pris des mesures avec
nos partenaires européens qui a permis
de multiplier les capacités de
production je ne rentre pas dans les
détails les tensions sur les médicaments
anesthésiants impact nécessairement vous
l'avez évoqué la reprise des activités
chirurgicales et le retour à la normale
et ce retour à la normale madame la
députée n'aura pas lieu avant l'été
et avant de reprendre une activité à 100
% afin d'exclure toute rupture de stock
nous envisageons plutôt un redémarrage
progressif et ainsi nous avons demandé
aux agences régionales de santé
d'échanger pour définir en fonction des
approvisionnements en médicaments
nécessaires la réanimation à quel rythme
la reprise de la chirurgie lourde doit
être programmé et de partager ce travail
évidemment avec les établissements de
santé les engagements pris pour ainsi
être respectée tant à l'égard des
opérations qui sont programmés
qu'évidemment des patients et merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame delphine bagarry
merci merci monsieur brice dans
l'organisation du ségur se fait autour
de trois actes de 300 acteurs
institutionnels élus agences régionales
de santé financeurs sandisk à
hospitalier cetera
nous sommes cependant alerté par
différents représentants de
professionnels de santé ou du monde
médico-social qui ne trouvent pas leur
place dans cette concertation
je pense ici aux ambulanciers
hospitalier ou sage-femme au psychologue
aux orthophonistes aude et éthicienne
aidé et éthicien aux ergothérapeute aux
aides à domicile aussi la liste est
longue et j'en oublie c'est sûr tous
ceux et toutes celles qui ont pu se
sentir écarté du soin lors du
confinement et qui sont pourtant
indispensables à une prise en charge
sanitaire et sociale globale dans une
stratégie aussi bien curative que
préventive des professionnels pour
lesquels la revalorisation des statuts
et des salaires est aussi essentiel
pouvez vous nous assurez monsieur le
ministre que toutes les voix tous les
acteurs du soin qui sont d'ailleurs
souvent des actrices tous des oubliés du
ségur seront entendus ma seconde
question concerne la déclinaison
territoriale du ségur de la santé
comment s'assurer que la voix des
territoires sera bien entendu ne peut
pas y avoir de sortie de crise sans
décompte des cloisonnements de l'hôpital
sans renforcement de l'offre
territoriale de soins comment faire pour
ne pas retourner dans la caricature d'un
hospital au centrisme suranné comment
s'assurer que la voie des collectivités
qui sont les acteurs de première ligne
contre les tensions territoriale de
l'offre de soins sera entendu je pense
en particulier au maire
qui se mobilisent faut créer des centres
de santé communaux aux élus et usagers
qui se bat pour maintenir des services
hospitaliers ou que simplement leur
hôtel glissement de santé soient
préservés ensemble comment penser le
ségur non pas seulement comme une
réforme hospitalière mais aussi comme un
projet pleinement intégré dans
l'aménagement du territoire avec tous
les professionnels pour tous les
patients que nous sommes dans la
continuité de la formidable énergie qu'a
été cette émaner des territoires
la parole est à monsieur le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre des
solidarités de la santé est monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la députée je vais
essayer de me montrer à sa hauteur je
peux vous l'assurer madame la députée il
n'est pas il n'est pas d'oublier du
ségur dès le début dès la semaine
dernière dès le lancement par le premier
ministre par le ministre des solidarités
de la santé le choix a été fait de
convier un nombre très très large
deux professionnels de participants du
monde de la santé de l'ensemble de cette
chaîne qui fait notre système de santé
l'hôpital la ville le médico-social et
ce sont près de 300 personnes qui ont
ainsi lancé le ségur à nos côtés mardi
dernier olive et veyran installé le
comité national ségur dans l'animation a
été confiée vous le savez à nicole notât
puis le groupe national sur les
carrières et les rémunérations avec des
concertations qui se tiendront jusqu'à
la fin du mois de juin
je comprends nous entendons le souhait
d'un grand nombre d'acteurs de
participer à cette concertation c'est
tout le sens de votre question et j'ai
envie de me réjouir ce que si tout le
monde veut y participer
c'est bien que tout le monde que ce ce
ségur charrie beaucoup d'attentes et
qu'il est digne d'intérêt
alors le ministre a eu l'occasion de
préciser les membres du comité national
c'est dur qui n'ont pas eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer à l'occasion de son
installation pourront évidemment le
faire lors des prochaines conservation
qui vont se dérouler chaque semaine et
le cas échéant comme c'est de tradition
par des contributions écrites qui bien
évidemment viendront alimenter la
réflexion et l'élaboration de de ce plan
les participants et l'ensemble des
acteurs sont en parallèle pardon des
sessions de partage d'expériences ont
été lancées vendredi à
jeudi à dijon car vous l'avez évoqué et
là aussi c'est un parti pris fort du
ministère dès le début du lancement de
cette concertation c'est de faire
remonter des territoires les partages
d'expériences au plus près de ce qu'ont
vécu les professeurs professionnels de
santé depuis cette crise et c'est pour
nous un élément central de l'élaboration
qui est un qui est en cours tout comme
la participation des professionnels
directement sur une plateforme en ligne
qui sera mise à disposition dans les
jours qui viennent le cieux le ministre
la parole tavaléa bolivia grégoire merci
monsieur le président c'est avec une
certaine émotion et au nom de l'ensemble
du groupe la république en marche que je
souhaite aussi exprimé notre entière
solidarité et notre mémoire de claude
goasguen avec lequel pour ma part j'ai
eu l'honneur de grandir et de beaucoup
apprendre en mémoire de claude de sa
carrure de savoir de son savoir de son
droit romain vous l'avez dit président
il faisait partie des rares qui
maîtrisait un savoir aujourd'hui perdu
je voudrais lui dédier cette citation de
virgile de l'énéide qu'il m'avait
apprise à aude aqesss fortuna you what
voilà vous traduirez vous-même aux
audacieux la chance sourit toujours
s'était résolument un audacieux et je
garderai en mémoire c'est sacré coup de
gueule qui peu importe les bords nous
manqueront je n'en doute pas monsieur le
ministre de l'économie
face à la pandémie le gouvernement a
réagi a réagi vite réagit fort en
soutenant la trésorerie de plus de 500
mille entreprises avec le pg e en
élargissant au sein de deux projets de
loi de finances rectificative le fonds
de solidarité en le prolongeant pour
certains jusqu'à la fin d'année 2020
mais aussi en assurant vous le savez le
chômage partiel à plus de 12 millions de
salariés mais le temps du soutien d'âtre
presque déjà dit hier et c'est celui de
la refondation qu'il nous faut imaginer
demain mais entre les deux
urgence et aujourd'hui l'urgence vous le
savez l'urgence c'est la relance nous
voyons d'ici deux là se multiplier des
propositions de plans de relance eux s'y
adapter que plus ou moins inspirés on a
vu la commission européenne agir avec un
pas historique en proposant à
l'instigation de la france et de
l'allemagne les missions d'une dette
mutualisée
on voit aussi des idées recyclés en 2020
des propositions 2017 et pour certaines
de 2012 en bref tout le monde réfléchit
à son plan de relance
mais c'est naturellement le vôtre celui
du gouvernement qui est attendu monsieur
le ministre
parce que la nature et la forme de la
relance qu'il choisira détermineront la
nature et la forme de la reprise
monsieur le ministre
au delà du plan sectoriel les plans
sectoriels comment escompté vous scandé
les prochaines semaines en vue du client
de quitter mes chers collègues ne vous
indignez pas de 15 secondes de débord
qui ont été justifiées par l'hommage
rendu à notre collègue west guns la
parole la parole est à monsieur bruno le
maire -ministre de l'économie et des
finances monsieur le président madame la
députée olivia à grégoire
vous l'avez rappelé je crois que nous
avons apporté une réponse immédiate à la
hauteur des enjeux aux salariés et aux
entreprises touchées par une crise qui
je le rappel va amener une récession de
11 points en 2020 c'est la récession la
plus grave depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale en france
nous entrons maintenant dans un deuxième
temps de la réponse celui où va falloir
accompagner tous les secteurs qui ont
été les plus durement touchés et donc
nous avons commencé à mettre en place
avec le premier ministre et le président
de la république un certain nombre de
plans sectoriels pour accompagner le
tourisme l'hôtellerie la restauration
l'industrie automobile ça a été annoncé
par le président de la république la
semaine dernière l'aéronautique
nous annoncerons un plan ambitieux avec
le président de la république sans doute
en début de semaine prochaine
l'ateq pour éviter que nos startups soit
racheté par les gens du numérique le
bâtiment les travaux publics
toutes ces mesures de soutien feront
l'objet d'un projet de loi de finances
rectificative numéro 3 que nous
présenterons avec le ministre de
l'action des comptes publics le 10 juin
prochain en conseil des ministres et
puis viendra un troisième temps celui de
la relance nationale
cette relance elle devra être audacieuse
et elle devra refaire le lien avec notre
politique économique pour l'offre pour
les entreprises pour la compétitivité
pour l'innovation parce que cette
politique et vous pouvez en être fier
surtout c'est bon elle avait marché et
nous avait donné l'un des plus hauts
niveaux de croissance de la zone euro
1.5 de croissance juste avant la crise
elle devrait être coordonnée avec tous
nos partenaires européens et elle devra
être verte
nous voulons saisir l'occasion de cette
relance pour transformer notre modèle
économique qui soit modèle économique
décarbonés respectueux de
l'environnement est conforme aux
attentes de l'immense majorité de nos
citoyens faujour de cette crise
la chance d'un rebond vers pour notre
économie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur fabien roussel
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances renault licencie 4600
emplois et l'état actionnaire accorde 5
milliards d'euros d'argent public pour
cela des dizaines de milliers d'hommes
et de femmes salariées du groupe ou sous
traitants ont peur de perdre leur
travail ou de faire encore des
sacrifices pour le garder oui c'est
encore le monde du travail qui doit
payer
alors que le problème ce n'est pas la
pandémie mais plutôt les choix du groupe
de délocaliser de nourrir d'abord les
actionnaires 4,8 milliards d'euros de
dividendes versés depuis 2013 au
détriment d'investissements en france
dans la sambre dans le nord où mc a
produit le kangoo nous sommes tous
unis pour conserver les 2100 emplois sur
place vous déclarez que renault a un an
pour garantir un projet industriel à
maubeuge mais le projet existe monsieur
le ministre c'est le nouvel utilitaire x
f k qui doit sortir en février
pouvez vous confirmer qu'il sera produit
à maubeuge comme prévu mais il ya aussi
choisi flins caudan mêmes dieppe à long
terme menacés par ce plan s'il n'est pas
remise en cause
avec en prime de l'argent public les
députés communistes vous font donc une
autre proposition que l'argent public
notre argent sert à relocaliser en
france la production de petites voitures
populaires pas cher électriques hybrides
et thermique relocalisons les clio
twingo dacia vendus en france mais
fabriqué en turquie en roumanie et en
slovénie
là bas les usines tournent 7 jours sur 7
elles sont surchargés il suffirait de
rapatrier 300 mille véhicules pour
charger les usines françaises
cela coûterait quelques centaines
d'euros de plus par voiture
mais ce serait du made in france
l'argent public l'argent des français
doit servir à cela m'a fait mal aux yeux
du député vous la parole est à rémy est
à monsieur bruno le maire venez de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
député fabien roussel
je pense que nous devons la vérité aux
français sur la situation de renault
renault perd de l'argent chaque mois et
pas des centimes d'euro des centaines de
millions d'euros
renault a une capacité de production de
un peu plus d'un million de véhicules en
france chaque année ils en produisent un
peu plus de 600 milles dont 40 % de
capacité industrielle qui ne sont pas
utilisés donc pour dire les choses
simplement monsieur député roussel je
sais que vous connaissez parfaitement la
situation de renault
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est la survie de
l'un des premiers constructeurs
industriels automobile français qui fait
partie de notre histoire
et croyez moi
je suis totalement déterminé à ce que
nous réussissions à maintenir renault à
le développer et en faire l'un des
grands constructeurs industriels
automobiles du 21e siècle
et pour ça il faut trois choses d'abord
il faut une stratégie et notre stratégie
lé clair renault doit être l'excellent
constructeurs en matière de construction
de véhicules électriques de nouvelle
génération est autonome et je souhaite
notamment que le département du nord
devienne le lieu d'excellence en
production des véhicules électriques
utilitaires légers de renault comme vous
le proposez
cette stratégie se sont donc celles de
la valeur qui doit être relocalisé en
france comme renault annoncé qu'il re
localiseraient son moteur électrique de
chine en france
la deuxième condition c'est le dialogue
c'est le dialogue que j'ai eu ce matin
avec les salariés de maubeuge et nous
avons demandé à renault de préserver
l'emploi et les capacités industrielles
à maubeuge au delà de 2023 et nous avons
obtenu un accord sur ce sujet et la
troisième condition
bah c'est le soutien de l'état et c'est
bien pour cela que je signerai à la
suite de cet accord le prêt garanti de
l'état de 5 milliards d'euros pour aider
renault à se développer et réussir au
21ème siècle
merci monsieur le ministre la parole et
faire la catherine au son monsieur le
ministre
l'industrie textile française souffre
depuis de longues années après naf naf
où le groupe vivarte une nouvelle grande
enseigne de la distribution textile se
trouve en très grande difficulté
l'entreprise camaïeu constitue au même
titre que la redoute ou jules des
symboles industrielle dans ma
circonscription de roubaix wattrelos
mais aussi pour tout le versant nord-est
de l'agglomération lilloise
l'annnonce du dépôt de bilan de
l'entreprise camaïeu est la goutte d'eau
qui fait déborder le vase dans un
secteur où le taux de chômage est un des
plus élevés de france et dans lequel les
indicateurs sociaux sont au plus bas
au delà des centaines d'emplois menacés
directement par cette annonce ce sont
des milliers d'autres qui pourraient
être mis en péril
en cas de fermeture de camaïeu
de par son implantation historique dans
ma circonscription moi même alors jeune
étudiante j'y travaillais pour financer
mes études et nous sommes des milliers
dans ce cas avant la crise sanitaire
liée aux qu'ovide les actionnaires
avaient envisagé un plan de
refinancement de l'entreprise mais
s'était heurté à des banques peut aller
coûte aujourd'hui encore les banques
refusent à l'entreprise un pg e
depuis des années le versant nord-est de
la métropole lilloise soufre et de
nombreux partenaires se mobilisent pour
atténuer les effets de la
désindustrialisation massive et soudaine
de notre secteur
refusant ainsi de baisser les bras
devant le fatalisme affichée par
certaines de nos institutions
je me bats tous les jours sur le terrain
pour ôter de la tête de mes concitoyens
qu'ils sont condamnés à vivoter grâce
aux aides publiques
nous avons besoin de vous il est grand
temps aujourd'hui de donner un bassin de
plus de 350 mille habitants les moyens
d'un nouvel avenir social professionnel
et environnemental monsieur le ministre
quelles sont les mesures que vous
comptez prendre pour sauver camaïeu mais
aussi l'ensemble de la filière textile
française et lui donner les perspectives
d'évolution pour les années à venir
merci je relaie la parole est à monsieur
bruno le maire -ministre de l'économie
et des finances il madame la députée
d'abord je voudrais saluer votre
mobilisation sur ce sujet et je voudrais
profiter aussi de votre question pour
saluer tous les salariés de l'industrie
textile qui depuis des mois se sont
mobilisés pour produire des masses pour
produire des blues et pour aider tous
les personnels soignants et tous les
français à disposer des équipements dont
ils ont impérativement besoin
les problèmes de camaïeu les problèmes
de la halle de date malheureusement pas
de la crise du coronavirus et ce sont de
conforama aussi ce sont des problèmes
structurels que nous avons essayé de
régler bien avant la crise nous étions
dans le cadre de cabaye ou sur le point
de conclure un accord avec les
actionnaires avant que la crise ne
conduise à nouveau besoin de financement
de 100 millions d'euros pour
l'entreprise il ya 4000 salariés qui
sont en jeu
je voudrais les rassurer nous trouverons
une solution sans doute sous forme de
reprise comme pour le cas de la halle
comme pour le cas de conforama parce que
c'est la meilleure solution industrielle
et c'est la meilleure solution pour
l'emploi mais croyez moi
sur tous ces sujets là mais qui
malheureusement ne se limite pas aux
trois sujets que j'ai cité les services
de l'état sont totalement mobilisés avec
les services de la région avec les élus
locaux pour apporter des solutions et
préserver l'emploi qui est évidemment ce
qu'il ya de plus précieux sur le long
terme
ça doit nous amener notamment dans la
perspective du plan de relance à
réfléchir au meilleur moyen de
relocaliser l'activité industrielle
entre pays comment est ce que l'on fait
revenir des emplois de l'activité des
usines là ça suppose de la formation ça
suppose une politique fiscale attractive
ça suppose comme je le propose depuis
plusieurs mois de baisser des impôts de
production pour que les usines soient
plus rentable et plus compétitive par
rapport à nos grands voisins et ça
suppose enfin de continuer à innover
investir par exemple dans les textiles
moderne dans les textiles à haute valeur
ajoutée dans les textiles technologique
qui feront sans doute l'avenir de la
filière textile dans notre pays merci
monsieur analystes la parole à madame
laurence dumont merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre il ya un
mois le président demande est
étrangement aux acteurs de la culture
d'enfourcher le tigre expression qui
enjambe allègrement les 45 milliards
d'euros que la culture pèse en termes
économiques expression déplacé vis-à-vis
des plus de 600000 personnes qui font
vivre ce secteur pour nombre d'entre
elles et pour les gens du spectacle
relevant du régime général je pense aux
extras aux guides aux gens du cathérine
aux hôtesses aux jeunes agents de
sécurité et j'en oublie
pour enfourcher le tigre ce sera surtout
après le vote d'un amendement
gouvernemental au sénat
enfourcher le chômage et si votre
réforme d'assurance chômage n'est pas
annulé en septembre une indemnisation
lourdement aggravé pour ces deux
millions de salariés à emploi discontinu
enfourché le tigre pour les théâtres dit
public c'est surtout enfourcher un
système injuste qui ne leur permet pas
d'accéder au chômage partiel pour leur
contrat d'artiste intermittents
enfin enfourché le tigre pour les
intermittents
c'est certes un soulagement avec le
renvoi au 31 août 2021
mais on sait tous que la culture sera
parmi les derniers secteur à sortir du
confinement
ils ne bénéficieront donc pas d'une
année blanche mais de 8 ou 10 mois selon
la reprise pour faire leurs heures et
que dire de ces interventions d'artistes
évoquée par le président de la
république dans le cadre des vacances
apprenantes aucune visibilité et un vrai
risque de requalification de ses
contrats qui les sortiraient de
l'intermittence monsieur le ministre
tous ces dangers sont devant nous alors
allez vous protéger tous les
intermittents de l'emploi dans la
culture tous les intermittents du
spectacle et aider lé théâtre notamment
public à passer le cap de cette crise
faute de quoi c'est nous tous qui
serions privés demain d'une partie de
cette magnifique scène française merci
va débuter la parole et à monsieur
franck riester ministre de la culture
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
députés messieurs les députés
madame la députée du monde le
gouvernement le président de la
république depuis le début de la crise
est mobilisé pour les arts et la culture
faire en sorte que tous les dispositifs
transversaux puissent bénéficier au
secteur de la culture
ça a été le cas pour le prêt garanti par
l'état pour le fonds de solidarité pour
les reports de charges pour le chômage
partiel
nous avons accompagné des dispositifs
spécifiques menées par nos opérateurs le
cnc le cnm le cnl le cnap pour
accompagner ce secteur le président de
la république il y a quelques semaines a
été très clair sur sa volonté
d'accompagner le secteur dans la reprise
et ensuite dans la relance
en annonçant un dispositif exceptionnel
unique au monde
la députée unique au monde de prolonger
les droits des intermittents du
spectacle jusqu'à fin août 2021
c'est une sécurité pour tous ces
artistes ces techniciens du cinéma de
l'audiovisuel
elle est du spectacle vivant qui va leur
permettre de pouvoir dans les semaines
les mois qui viennent recommencé à avoir
de l'activité sans se demander si oui ou
non ils vont pouvoir vivre à la fin du
mois c'est un dispositif unique
c'est un dispositif dont on est très
fiers et qui va permettre encore une
fois d'accompagner la relance du secteur
nous avons commencé à donner la
possibilité à des spectacles de pouvoir
rejouer progressivement ça sera
évidemment avec des contraintes pour
celles et ceux qui jouent pour celles et
ceux qui organise ses spectacles
nous allons veiller dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent de faire en sorte
de leur donner les moyens de compenser
ses difficultés pour que très vite
partout en france pour le cinéma pour
l'audiovisuel et pour le spectacle
vivant nous puissions retrouver les
chemins du plaisir des spectateurs et
les téléspectateurs
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
véronique louwagie
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
au premier trimestre 2001 la france a
connu la pire récession de tous les pays
européens avec un pub en baisse de 5,8
pour cent en un trimestre ne paient
encore plus frappés que l'espagne ou
l'italie
nous sommes confrontés à une gigantesque
crise économique avec une chute du pib'
annoncé le 11 % pour 2020 alors que la
situation de notre pays était déjà très
fragilisée
tout cela pour dire que l'enjeu de la
relance est énorme
il ne faut pas se manquer le
gouvernement a annoncé une myriade de
plans de relance sectoriels
c'est très bien quoique difficile à
suivre
j'ai aussi beaucoup de mal à suivre
votre majorité qui est un joug dit qu'il
faut baisser les impôts et un autre à
l'air de considérer que les taxes sont
la solution à tous nos problèmes ou
qu'il serait bon de forcer les français
à faire preuve de solidarité
or la relance ne peut se mettre en
oeuvre sans une ligne claire et une
ligne précise limpide
quelle est votre stratégie en matière
d'impôts par ailleurs la relance devra
aussi permettre de reconstruire une
économie compétitive souveraine et
durable mais il faut aussi viser
juste et penser collectif joué collectif
c'est associer tous les acteurs
envisagez-vous par exemple de laisser
l'entreprise négocier en matière de
temps de travail permettant une
augmentation des salaires
envisagez-vous un soutien de l'état pour
l' embauche des jeunes afin qu'une
génération ne soit pas sacrifiée et
surtout allez vous créer une année
blanche fiscales et sociales pour les
pme les tpe en transformant les reports
de charges en annulation de charges
fiscales et sociales
la crise inédite que nous traversons
nous impose pour sauver nos emplois et
remettre en selle notre économie
d'apporter les bonnes réponses à ces
questions je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et à
monsieur bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie et des finances madame la
députée véronique louwagie
merci de me donner l'occasion de
clarifier nouvelle fois la stratégie
économique du gouvernement face à cette
crise j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
d'expliquer la réponse massive et
immédiate qui je crois a été saluée par
les entrepreneurs eux mêmes qu'ils
soient petits commerçants ou grands
chefs d'entreprise je maintiens qu'il
est indispensable d'avoir des
dispositifs sectoriels pour soutenir
l'aéronautique l'automobile tous les
secteurs qui sont les plus durement
touchés aujourd'hui et je suis convaincu
que vous aurez à coeur de voter ce
projet de loi de finances numéro 3 qui
permettra justement d'apporter à tous
ces secteurs le tourisme également le
soutien dont ils ont besoin ensuite
viendra le temps de définir en septembre
la stratégie sur plusieurs années de
relance national est comme gelée indiqué
comme l'a souhaité le premier ministre
et de président de la république
nous consulterons tous les groupes
politiques et chacun pourra apporter ses
propositions
la stratégie du gouvernement elle elle
tient en trois mots une politique de
l'offre parce que c'est elle qui marche
parce que c'est elle qui crée des
emplois
parce que c'est elle qui permet
d'innover et d'avoir une relance verte
parce que c'est elle qui a donné des
résultats pendant les trois premières
années du quinquennat et qu'il n'y a
aucune raison d'abandonner une politique
qui avait donné de bons résultats pour
la fin
le deuxième mot d'ordre c'est les
salariés et la ministre du travail mme
moyal pénicaud apportera toutes les
précisions sur le soutien aux salariés
et notamment le soutien aux jeunes qui
vont rentrer sur le marché du travail et
qui sont notre première préoccupation
la troisième mot d'ordre enfin c'est la
coordination européenne
nous avons grâce à l'accord conclu entre
le président république et la
chancelière allemande
aujourd'hui 1300 milliards d'euros à
notre disposition pour moderniser notre
économie et nous permettre de passer ce
cap difficile
je pense que nous saurons faire bon
usage de cet argent européen politique
de l'offre soutien aux salariés
coordination européenne
c'est ce qui doit permettre à la france
de sortir plus forte de cette crise
économique merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame béatrice descamps
merci messieurs ont donné moins cher
collègue madame logis à 8 secondes
devant elle merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vous n'avez pas
répondu à toutes mes questions notamment
à celles qui concernent l'impôt shoot à
vous dire que le groupe l'est
républicain a présenté aujourd'hui son
propre plan de relance je voudrais vous
rappeler la devise qui est simple
libérer l'entreprise avec zéro impôt
supplémentaire et zéro contrainte
supplémentaire j'espère que vous
prendrez en compte deux camps
si monsieur le président messieurs
ministre de l'économie et des finances
le 8 novembre 2018
la visite du président de la république
dans les travées de maubeuge
construction automobile s'était
accompagné de belles promesses sur son
avenir et son investissement ainsi que
la signature d'un pacte territorial pour
la réindustrialisation de la sambre
avesnois thiérache à territoire qui a
fortement besoin d'être soutenus or le
lancement d'une concertation pour
étudier la création d'un pôle
d'excellence optimisée des véhicules
électriques et utilisait utilitaires
légers dans le nord de la france
laissait craindre une mise en danger sur
le site de maubeuge 2006 emplois directs
cdi 900 emplois directs cdd et intérim
et des milliers d'emplois indirects chez
les sous traitants en sambre avesnois
rappelons que mca et
usine la plus productive du groupe
renault en europe grâce à son travail
d'optimisation et aux projets de
désenclavement et de développement des
infrastructures
monsieur ministre pour faire suite à la
forte mobilisation de samedi dernier des
habitants de la sambre avesnois et de
nombreux élus du nord derrière leur le
maire de maubeuge arnaud de kani je suis
était initialement vous interroger sur
les garanties concrètes que le président
de la république comptait mettre en
oeuvre pour tenir ses engagements
vis-à-vis de la sambre avesnois et de
mca
or nous savons depuis ce midi que
certains engagements ont été annoncés ce
matin lors d'une réunion dans votre
ministère où vous avez rencontré et
écouté les salariés les élus de maubeuge
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre précise
et ici le contenu de ces engagements et
la manière dont ceux ci pourront être
tenus je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie et des finances
oui madame la députée béatrice descamps
je vous confirme que j'ai reçu ce matin
en présence du président de renault les
représentants des salariés de l'usiné de
maubeuge
les élus locaux et un certain nombre de
représentants dont la députée alors
quatre lots dont je salue la
mobilisation sur ce sujet
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que j'ai ressenti en écoutant
les représentants des salariés de
l'incompréhension et de la colère de
l'incompréhension parce qu'il représente
un site vous l'avez très bien dit qui
est un des plus productifs en europe et
donc c'est difficile pour des salariés
alors qu'ils ont réussi qu'ils ont
travaillé qu'ils sortent des véhicules
dans des conditions de compétitivité qui
sont exceptionnelles de se dire tiens
peut-être que nous pourrions disparaître
d'ici quelques mois au d'ici quelques
années
c'est incompréhensible et inacceptable
pour ses salariés et de la colère parce
que dans la situation de crise où nous
sommes aujourd'hui la perspective de
voir son emploi disparaître suscite
légitimement de la colère et de
l'inquiétude chez les salariés et c'est
les familles des sly je pense qu'au bout
d'une heure et demie de discussions nous
avons répondu à cette inquiétude et nous
avons trouvé un accord avec la direction
de renault avec les syndicats pour que
sur le site de maubeuge l'emploi et les
capacités industrielles soient préservés
au delà de 2023
qui était la fille date fatidique qui
inquiétait les salariés et qui
inquiétait leurs familles nous allons
utiliser la période qui vient pour
ouvrir une concertation sociale une
présentation technique voir comment
est-ce que l'on peut garantir cette
activité quelles sont les perspectives
qu'elles sont les meilleures solutions
industrielles
la discussion va s'ouvrir dès la semaine
prochaine pour regarder toutes les
options
une fois encore dans le cadre de cette
garantie sur l'emploi et sur l'activité
industrielle au delà de 2023 sur le site
et je me suis engagé à voir un nouveau
rendez vous en septembre avec l'ensemble
des participants à cette réunion pour
que chacun soit rassuré mais la
définition du nord un site d'excellence
pour dont la parole est à monsieur
thibault bazin a pendant des combats
mais quand quelques secondes donc très
rapidement bien sûr je voulais remercier
monsieur le ministre effectivement je
pense que
les représentants syndicaux les élus ont
été rassurés mais c'est avec beaucoup
d'attention que nous suivrons bien
évidemment les étapes de ce dossier
merci jean collet s'est coupé la parole
à monsieur thibault bazin merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre je tire la sonnette d'alarmé
la crise que nous traversons a
directement impacté le bâtiment
provoquant l'arrêt brutal des chantiers
si les entreprises ont été aidées par
des mesures financières les pertes
subies reste importante et s'accumulent
la reprise de l'activité se fait
progressivement et trop partiellement
dans des conditions d'adaptation
difficile très coûteuse plusieurs
raisons à cela
l'important c'est la lourdeur des
mesures sanitaires le refus de beaucoup
de particuliers propriétaires ou
locataires de voir une reprise des
travaux ce qui impacte les artisans les
problèmes rencontrés dans la chaîne
logistique
la baisse de la commande plusieurs
nécessité s'impose le partage des
surcoûts imputables au covan 19 ainsi
que les coûts indirects induits par la
nouvelle organisation mise en place le
soutien aux investissements locaux des
mesures fortes de soutien la commande
publique
cette crise doit être surtout l'occasion
d'aider mieux les particuliers afin de
développer les chantiers alors monsieur
le premier ministre
allez vous enfin prendre les bonnes
mesures afin de vraiment relancer
l'activité
merci la parole est à monsieur bruno le
maire -ministre de l'économie et des
finances
mais monsieur le député thibeault bazin
je partage votre appréciation sur le
bâtiment sain secteurs clés de notre
économie
il a été quasiment à l'arrêt 85% des
chantiers ont été à l'arrêt pendant la
crise du pot vide et il a redémarré il a
redémarré fortement et tant mieux pour
tout le monde parce que c'est des
garanties d'emploi et d'activité sur le
territoire mais il est handicapé par des
règles sanitaires qui lui font perdre 25
à 30 % de productivité sur chaque
chantier
il suffit de visiter un chantier pour
voir qu effectivement sur la base vie ça
circule moins bien que pour faire les
coffrages pour faire les soudures pour
monter les étages mais à chaque fois
c'est des contraintes supplémentaires
qui pèsent sur la productivité des
chantiers et il y à des surcoûts dans le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
du verrou 3 nous aurons l'occasion
d'examiner les moyens de prendre en
charge ces surcoûts pour que
effectivement ça ne pèse pas sur la
rentabilité des chantiers de bâtiments
et sur les chantiers de travaux publics
et deuxième réponse qui peut être
apportée c'est celle qui passe par la
commande publique et par le soutien aux
collectivités locales et je rappelle que
le prémunissent annoncé il y a quelques
jours un soutien massif de plusieurs
milliards d'euros aux collectivités
locales qui doit lui permettre aussi
d'accompagner cette reprise la commande
publique et de soutenir le bâtiment et
les travaux publics
enfin troisième élément il faut garder
un environnement qui soit le plus
compétitif possible
ça passe là aussi je le redis par la
baisse des impôts de production qui pèse
sur la compétitivité des entreprises et
sur leur rentabilité
merci monsieur le député merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre il ya
des choses qui vont dans le bon sens
mais cela ne me semble pas suffisant il
faut un véritable plan de relance plus
ambitieux n'est ce pas le moment de
baisser le taux de tva de 10 à 5 5 pour
tous les travaux de rénovation n'est ce
pas le moment de remettre en place apl
accession qui permettrait à des ménages
modestes d'accéder à la propriété
n'est ce pas le moment de reconsidérer
votre politique de logement trop centrée
sur les métropoles afin de n'oublier
aucun territoire alors que nous avons
tous été confinée pendant tant de
semaines le besoin de bien se loger a
encore plus de sens aujourd'hui
il convient à monsieur le ministre de
reconsidérer le logement comme un bien
essentiel
l'adage dit quand le bâtiment va tout va
pour y parvenir fait plus juste
socialement plus équitable
territorialement et surtout relancer
l'activité par des mesures fortes
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
non bien ma parole est à monsieur boris
flo
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre du travail après des alertes
des organisations syndicales ces
dernières semaines c'est le cabinet
technologia qui a fait paraître il ya
quelques jours une étude suggérant que
de très nombreux abus au chômage partiel
seraient constatés dispositif dont
chacun mesure la nécessité que pour
notre part nous souhaitons voir
prolonger c'est ainsi que pour plus de
la moitié des 2720 élus et responsables
syndicaux interrogés
eh bien il indique que de très nombreux
salariés sous ce dispositif aurait
continué à travailler dans le détail
environ 24 % affirment que les salaires
ayant poursuivi leur tâche
à la demande de l'employeur tandis que 1
car indique que d'autres salariés ont
continué de travailler de leur propre
chef
par crainte de perdre leur emploi par la
suite il n'y a évidemment pas
d'intention maligne mais il y avait la
responsabilité de l'employeur de
vérifier que les salariés ne travaillez
pas enfin certains salariés ont même
dénoncé des horaires de travail qui ne
correspondent pas au final du tout à la
réalité du chômage partiel dans lequel
il était censé avoir été placé ces
chiffres évidemment nous interpelle par
leur ampleur parce que le soutien de la
nation à ces entreprises est alors à
leurs salariés est une forme de pacte
avec les français il serait extrêmement
grave
en effet qu'ils y portent atteinte nous
savons que pour une part des entreprises
il a fallu s'adapter face à l'ampleur de
la prise qui était difficile de mesurer
en amont madame la ministre le ministre
ministère du travail a lancé via les
directs une grande campagne de contrôle
pouvez vous nous dire si cette campagne
corrobore cette étude est indiqué la
représentation nationale ce qui relève
réellement d'abus intentionnelle
manifeste et ce qui peut être considéré
comme une négligence ou des erreurs
d'employeurs de bonne foi pouvez-vous
enfin nous indiquer qu'elle sera les
intentions
du gouvernement dès lors que ces abus
seraient constatés en termes de demande
de remboursement ou éventuellement de
poursuites je remercie madame la
ministre
merci chers collègues la parole était
malade muriel pénicaud ministre du
travail monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député boris vallot vous l'avais dit je
crois qu'il ya presque un consensus sur
le sujet le chômage partiel massif
immédiat systématique a été nécessaire a
été très utiles pour préserver des
millions d'emplois dans le pays
ce sont plus d'un million d'entreprises
sur les 1 million 300 mille employeurs
qu'ils ont utilisés et au total sur les
trois mois ça veut dire qu environ 10 à
12 millions de salariés auront été
concernés ces 8 6 millions qui étaient
encore concernés effectivement chômage
partiel à fin avril
nous attendons les chiffres pour fin mai
qui devrait montrer une décrue alors
qu'on met en place quelque chose aussi
massif aussi efficace aussi rapide et
aussi systématique et encore une fois
préserver l'emploi était l'objectif au
dessus de tout eh bien il faut de la
confiance a priori et la confiance a
priori n'exclut pas et ben nécessite le
contrôle a posteriori nous sommes dans
cette phase là tout en accompagnant
évidemment la reprise de l'activité par
le chômage partiel
alors il ya un mois sans attendre
l'étude mais nous avions déjà des
alertes et de toute façon c'était prévu
nous avons commencé un plan de contrôle
assez systématique un plan de contrôle
et les premiers résultats de ce qu'on
voit pas ce qu'il ya des dizaines de
milliers de contrôler le programme et
c'est d'abord que pour une partie des
entreprises non négligeable c'est de
l'erreur la plupart des entreprises
n'avaient jamais qu ont recouru au
chômage partiel il ya beaucoup de
petites entreprises peuvent se tromper
dans la manière de calculer on leur
demande juste de rembourser il n'y a pas
de problème le droit à l'erreur doit
exister
et puis après il ya les fraudes c'est à
dire l'intention de frauder
et là c'est l'argent des français gérer
c'est même le risque de miner la
confiance dans un dispositif extrêmement
protecteurs donc là le code du travail
est très précis il y à des sanctions
possibles administrative amende de 30000
euros par emploi interdiction dette
publique pendant cinq ans mais aussi des
fonctions pénale possible donc
aujourd'hui laissés seuls les
organisations syndicales des salariés
nous font des alertes toutes les alertes
sont systématiquement examinés et par
ailleurs nous faisons du recoupement de
données administratives qui nous permet
d'avoir des présomptions
des risques vous l'avez souligné c'est
sur la bulle en matière de télétravail
et donc c'est une de nos cibles
prioritaires parce que c'est facile de
ford et la seringue de nos cibles
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur gérard manuel merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre je vais
vous parler du plan automobile et en ces
temps si particulier mais ce premier
ministre on peut tout vous reprocher
certains de vos choix d'avoir été les
mots l'expression un peu diesel au début
de la pandémie
je pense à la sphère des masques mais à
mon sens il est difficile de ne pas
reconnaître votre engagement dans la
fonction qui est la vôtre que vous
assumez avec un certain sens des
responsabilités et c'est tout à votre
honneur je vous le dis je vous le dis
d'autant plus que ça doit pas être
simple pour vous entoure et paraît-il
parce qu'ils se voient déjà votre place
et par un président qui multiplie ses
interventions avec une propension à
faire valser les milliards comme les
scories de ses rêves un le dernier plan
automobile mérite pour le moins quelques
explications concernant sa finalité
le 18 mai dernier les ministres de
l'économie annonce je cite un plan de
soutien aux voitures qui émettent le
moins de co2 aux voitures ouverte aux
voitures électriques et mardi derniers
d'étaples le président marc roux
insistait ce plan c'est investir pour
produire en france
alors j'ai trois questions la première
est ce que ces aides publiques a lancé
de soutien au secteur automobile sont
liés ou non à des objectifs de maintien
des sites et en maintien d'emplois
deuxième question les aides conséquentes
à l'achat des véhicules électriques
sachant la faible autonomie de ses
voitures à quel public sont elles
destinées comme deuxième voiture aux
habitants des métropoles et avez vous
pensé au monde rural qui se dépassent
plus souvent sur les distances longues
et dans le besoin de renouvellement est
là aussi très important troisième
question dans un plan d'avenir
prenons au plan des données
environnementales vous avez oublié les
filières vertueuse en émissions de co2 y
compris celles dans la phase de
construction du véhicule à savoir celle
de l'éthanol
du bio diesel et avoir fait l'impasse
sur la prometteuse filière de
l'hydrogène au moment même où la chine
annonce en faire la priorité pour
l'ensemble de sa mobilité je vous
remercie chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur bruno le maire
-ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le député et jean manuel je
connais votre attachement à l'industrie
automobile je la partage mais je pense
que vous n'avez pas lu précisément le
plan de soutien que nous avons proposé
avec le premier ministre et le président
de la république dans ce plan il y en a
pour toutes les familles de français
que vous aimiez l'électrique que vous
ayez un véhicule ancien que vous vouliez
le renouveler il y a à chaque fois une
proposition
si vous voulez vous acheter un véhicule
électrique neuf il reste très coûteux
bien sûr une dans 108 électrique ça
reste très cher une renault électrique
ça reste cher est pas accessible à
toutes les bourses mais il peut y avoir
un certain nombre de citadins qui
veulent ça chez sept types de véhicules
7000 euros de primes pour s'acheter un
véhicule électrique
si vous voulez changer votre vieux
véhicules toujours avec le même objectif
réduire les émissions de co2 dans notre
pays eh bien vous avez une prime à la
conversion
si vous avez un véhicule ancien vous
pouvez le faire pour un véhicule neuf ou
d'occasion dont vous voyez que le cas
que vous citez que je connais bien
puisque je suis je le rappelle et lui
d'un territoire rural d'une personne qui
aurait un vieux véhicules diesel et qui
voudraient le changer et prendre un
véhicule d'occasion pourrait bénéficier
de la prime à la conversion
elle peut même le cumuler avec la prime
pour le véhicule électrique voulait
acheter une hybride rechargeable y avait
pas de primes pour les hybrides
rechargeables nous mettons en place une
prime de 2000 euros pour les véhicules
hybrides rechargeables qui comme vous le
savez pas ce que vous êtes un
spécialiste sont le coeur de cible des
véhicules psa qui est leader dans le
domaine de l'hybride rechargeable
vous me dites payeur on oublie des
technologies prometteuses comme
hydrogène
enfin je rappelle que nous sommes quand
même l'un des premiers pays européens à
avoir mis en place un plan stratégique
de développement de la filière hydrogène
et que nous avons demandé que se mette
en place un plan de soutien européen à
la filière hydrogène et que nous allons
dans le plan de relance mettre en place
une filière spécifique pour le
développement l'hydrogène dans notre
pays donc soyez rassurés la voiture que
nous voulons pour demain
c'est une voiture propre
technologiquement avancés et vous avez
raison sur ce point
accessible à tous les français merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est amendable présidente
valérie rabault je remercie monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
ce matin le ministre de l'économie et
des finances a indiqué s'attendre à une
chute du pib de 11 % pour 2020 alors 11%
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que votre gouvernement
s'attend à ce que l'économie française
retrouve son niveau d'avant crise pas
une augmentation mais juste son niveau
d'avant crise pas avant décembre 2020
voire janvier 2021
monsieur le premier ministre il faut que
vous mettiez les cartes sur la table est
ce que vous vous attendez à ce que
l'économie française ne retrouve son
niveau d'avant crise qu'en janvier 2021
voir décembre 2020 si oui quels sont les
secteurs parce que là je pense qu'il
faut qu'on nous attaquions le dur quels
sont les secteurs pour lesquels vous
estimez qu'il n'y a pas de redémarrage
de l'économie à ce stade et qui ne
seront pas au rendez vous en décembre
2020 et janvier 2021
je vous remercie merci madame la
présidente la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
madame la présidente ras bol j'ai voulu
très humblement ne pas être certain
d'avoir compris le sens de votre
question je m'en excuse
je m'en excuse parce que j'étais non
mais j'ai été attentif je suis pas sûr
d'avoir totalement compris le sens de la
question j'essaie néanmoins de répondre
sur sur ce que je j'entrevois dans votre
question ou oui nous sommes nous allons
connaître un ralentissement économique
nous connaissons déjà en vérité un
ralentissement économique
macif reconnaissez avec moi madame la
présidente que je n'ai jamais fait
mystère de ce que je pensais que le choc
serait massif fait toujours dit le pas
de gaieté de coeur vous doutez bien mais
j'ai toujours dit parce que de toute
évidence lorsque vous interrompez aussi
massivement la production et la
consommation lorsque la moitié de
l'humanité se trouve confiné de toute
évidence la croissance économique le
cycle normal d achat de la production
des échanges se trouve entravée et donc
vous connaissez une réduction de la
création de richesse qui est à la fois
massive est préoccupante préoccupante
par ses effets nous y sommes et nous
voyons que dans beaucoup de pays du
monde
le choc économique la décroissance qui
s'annonce momentanée je l'espère je ne
fais pas partie de ceux qui pensent que
la décroissance serait la solution voyez
vous il ya mon avis vous non plus
d'ailleurs
enfin bref non mais ce qu'il ya des gens
qui pensent que la décroissance est la
solution
c'est respectable mais c'est respectable
mais en général c'est quelque chose
qu'on croit lorsque la croissance est
rapide lorsque la décroissance et là on
se rend compte que ça quand même
beaucoup d'inconvénients mais passons
sur 7 à 6
et donc nous voulons faire en sorte que
le choc subi par notre économie par
l'ensemble des économies européennes par
l'ensemble des économies mondiales soit
le plus limité possible pour pour
défendre l'emploi pour faire en sorte
que nos concitoyens ne vivent pas plus
mal demain que la façon dont ils
vivaient hier je ne sais pas dire madame
la présidente
quel sera l'impact de cette décroissance
momentanée je vois les chiffres certains
me disent mance % de pipe d'autres me
disent moins 10 d'autres me disent moins
12 g avec les prévisionnistes en matière
d'économie une relation de grand respect
mais quand même de distance soyez vous
parce que comme disait le sage la
prévision économique c'est toujours plus
facile après coup et après coup c'est
vrai qu'on se trompe - donc je ne sais
pas quel sera l'impact sur la croissance
des événements sanitaires que nous avons
connus mais de toute évidence il sera un
impact massif
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que ce choc
soit le plus rapidement absorbée alors
vous avez des économistes qui vous parle
d'un pacte en v2 courbe en l ou de
courbe en u
tout ça est admirable la vérité c'est
que nous devons tout faire pour que
l'attractivité économique de notre pays
les investissements là consommation
puisse repartir
et comme nous avons besoin d'une très
forte incitation publique pour que tout
ça reparte
nous devons mettre dans cette incitation
publique des choses à quoi nous croyons
faire en sorte que l'investissement qui
doit repartir soit plus vert qu'il
n'était faire en sorte que la
consommation qui doit repartir soit le
cas échéant et dans toute la mesure du
possible plus responsable que ce qu'elle
est et faire en sorte que notre économie
soit plus compétitive encore qu'elle ne
l'était pas au prix de reniement mais
parce que justement on sait y localiser
des talents de l'investissement du
capital oui du capital de la formation
de la compétence
c'est ça notre défi et nous verrons si
nous réussissons à faire en sorte que la
courbe soit la plus élevée possible et
je ne vais pas faire de paris sur la
forme de la courbe et sur la rapidité
avec laquelle nous allons remonter la
pente mais ce que nous devons faire tous
ensemble et c'est pour ça que les plans
sectoriels ont été annoncés et qu'ils
sont massifs
c'est faire en sorte que l'impact soit
le plus limité dans le temps possible
pour que notre pays puisse repartir de
l'avant et renouer madame la présidente
avec je le dis et je le dis avec non pas
avec ochoa satisfaction mais avec un
certain plaisir pour notre pays faire en
sorte que notre pays renoue avec trois
années où la croissance était forte ou
la création d'emplois étaient fortes ou
la diminution du chômage étaient
régulières ou l'attractivité du
territoire était grande
tous les investissements étrangers se
développer si nous pouvons renouer avec
ces éléments là alors d'autres pays aura
évidemment beaucoup mieux
madame la présidente vous avez la parole
oui si je vous ai posé la question
monsieur le premier ministre et parce
que je pense qu'il faut avoir une vision
un petit peu affiné secteur par secteur
quand on regarde notre économie le
moteur de notre économie c'est 60 % la
consommation 20% l'investissement 20 6%
les exportations les exportations ça va
être très compliqué sur la consommation
votre gouvernement n'a pas répondu aux
français le ministre de l'économie s'est
concentré uniquement sur la politique de
l'offre
or si vous voulez redémarrer la machine
économique il faut que la consommation
dans notre pays reparte
nous vous avions proposé que pour les
ménages qui ont les revenus les plus
faibles 300 euros par mois et 100 euros
par enfant
vous n'avez pas retenu cette proposition
nous vous proposons un plan d'une prime
climat qui est porté pour mon collègue
boris vallot et jean louis bricout
là-dessus votre gouvernement a dit non
nous vous avons proposé un vrais chèques
vacances les vacances vont consommer le
tourisme a besoin d'avoir des vacanciers
entre 300 et 700 euros
monsieur premier ministre là dessus vous
n'avez pas donné une réponse concrète
c'est ça que nous voulons aujourd'hui
pour maintenant pour tout de suite sinon
l'économie française ne retrouvera je
sais pas si c'est un v une racine carrée
ou je ne sais quoi son niveau pas avant
décembre janvier 2021 et peut-être même
après je vous remercie
merci mme la présidente la parole le
président b merci beaucoup monsieur le
président permettez moi d'associer les
députés du groupe agir ensemble à l'aube
âge que vous avez bien voulu rendre à
notre collègue de claude goasguen
monsieur le premier ministre la france
entre dans la quatrième semaine de
déconfinement et force est de constater
que votre méthode à la fois prudente
réaliste pragmatique fait de ce plan un
véritable succès n'en déplaise à ceux
qui ont voté contre
nous devons aujourd'hui faire face à une
crise économique et sociale qui
impliquera d'inventer des outils
nouveaux sur le plan économique pour
relancer notre économie dans un sens
plus respectueux de l'environnement mais
également de redéfinir un nouveau pacte
social qui permettent de ne laisser
personne au bord de la route
permettez-nous cependant d'attirer votre
attention aujourd'hui sur la situation
de ceux qui ne peuvent pas reprendre une
activité et cela pour trois raisons
d'abord pour une raison médicale je
pense notamment aux professions
indépendantes au commerçant qui souffre
d'une pathologie qui ferait qu'une
contamination au qu'ovide les amènerait
vers une mort certaine
y at il des solutions à envisager
peut-être le recours à une tierce
personne pour que ces activités puissent
reprendre
deuxièmement les personnes qui ne
peuvent reprendre leur activité du fait
des contraintes matérielles notamment
des gestes barrières
je pense notamment aux personnes
employées dans la restauration qui ne
pourront pas faute de table suffisante
reprendre leurs activités
enfin je pense troisièmement au jeu aux
créateurs de tout jeunes entreprises
celles qui ont été brutalement arrêtée
par le confinement et qui manquent
aujourd'hui de moyens financiers pour
relancer leurs activités
pouvez vous monsieur le premier ministre
nous donner quelques pistes de ce que le
gouvernement pourrait envisager pour
répondre à ces trois situations
merci mot merci chers collègues par
l'état monsieur merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le président en poste
mais question que vous posez sont
évidemment essentiel parce que nous
souhaitons tous la reprise nous ce sont
nous souhaitons tous qu'elle puisse être
la plus rapide la plus massive possible
pour compenser et pour essayer de
limiter les effets dans le temps de
cette crise sanitaire et donc de la
crise économique qui la suit sur nos
concitoyens mais il ya encore vous avez
raison de le dire des sujets des cas
plus difficiles que d'autres
d'une certaine façon en creux dans votre
réponse vous indiquer que l'engagement
massif par le gouvernement de mesures
générales a permis de répondre à
l'essentiel des questions mais certaines
certaines demeurent alors vous avez
évoqué la situation de ceux qui à raison
de leur fragilité
de santé peuvent difficilement reprendre
une activité qui imposerait une grande
proximité avec certains de nos
concitoyens
pour cela le principe est évidemment de
ne pas prendre de risque sanitaire mais
ce principe doit être adaptée dans le
temps entendons nous bien
si comme nous l'espérons au fur et à
mesure des jours qui passent l'épidémie
recule c'est à dire que le très faible
taux de positivité des tests nous
confirme que de moins en moins de virus
circule alors alors la raison que vous
indiquez aura vocation à disparaître
autrement dit je ne crois pas que nous
puissions nous installer durablement
dans le temps sur cette règle il faut
qu'elles interrompent que la protection
demeure et ça a été notre objectif dès
le début mais qu'elle s'interrompent
progressivement quand je ne sais pas
encore monsieur le président je suis
prudent en la matière sur la deuxième
chose nous avons indiqué en effet que le
principe maintenant c'était celui de la
reprise
il faut que dans toute la mesure du
possible les pans entiers de notre
économie puissent reprendre
certes en favorisant le télétravail
certes en adaptant les règles de
fonctionnement des entreprises
mais dans toute la mesure du possible
que notre activité l'activité de notre
pays puissent reprendre un des facteurs
limitants un des facteurs compliquent
est plutôt que dire limitant disons
compliqué c'est la possibilité pour les
parents et notamment pour les parents de
jeunes enfants de pouvoir concilier leur
activité professionnelle avec la garde
de leur enfant est bien entendu que si
les enfants ne peuvent pas retourner à
l'école pour telle ou telle raison
il est assez compliqué pour les parents
de trouver des solutions d'autant que
l'aide très souvent utiles des grands
parents est rendue compliquée par les
consignes que nous donnons de faire
attention aux personnes les plus âgées
donc les plus les plus fragiles
alors dans ce cas nous avons créé un
système qui permet de bénéficier du
chômage partiel
la raison veut que au fur et à mesure
que la crise sanitaire des croix nous
soyons de plus en plus exigeants non pas
du tout parce que nous n'aurions pas
confiance mais parce que chacun comprend
bien qu'il est normal d'être de plus en
plus exigeant avec ceux qui ayant des
jeunes enfants se prévalent de
l'impossibilité pour eux de les placer à
l'école
pour bénéficier du chômage partiel donc
de cette solidarité publique
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
indiqué qu'il fallait pour pouvoir en
bénéficier que l'école indique confirme
que non on ne pouvait pas accueillir ces
enfants
je crois que c'est certes une formalité
certes peut être délicate à accomplir je
ne le crois pas en vérité mais je pense
que chacun peut bien comprendre
l'intérêt qu'il ya à garantir le fait
que c'est bien une impossibilité qui
justifie la mise en oeuvre du chômage
partiel et pas simplement la volonté
soit de se préserver d'un risque soit
parfois même de profiter excessivement
d'un dispositif généreux enfin vous avez
évoqué la question et l'excellente
question des 13 jeunes entreprises
celles crées un mois avant le
confinement celle créée malheureusement
une semaine avant le confinement c'est
possible des entreprises qui ont été
créées après que des investissements ont
été réalisés et qui se sont trouvés dans
des situations redoutablement difficile
d'abord parce qu'elle ne pouvait pas
s'appuyer sur le passé pour démontrer
leur viabilité
nous avons prévu là encore de les
accompagner un texte réglementaire sera
pris dans le courant du mois de juin
pour accompagner les entreprises tout
récemment créé de façon à ce que les
plus jeunes et peut-être d'une certaine
façon les plus audacieux ne se voit pas
pénalisée par la crise sanitaire
merci monsieur le premier la parole est
à madame sabine rubin monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur le 25 mai
dernier aux états unis un afro américain
de 46 ans georges floyd était assassiné
par la police
la répression sociale et policières qui
s'exerce quotidiennement contre des
femmes et des hommes en raison de leur
couleur de peau sont des actes
abominables
d'ailleurs nos médias et politiques s'en
émeuve à juste titre mais hélas le
racisme n'est pas un produit
d'importation
nul besoin de traverser l'atlantique
pour rencontrer cette même répression
abusive
cette même discrimination alors que
george floyd agoniser à minneapolis a
bondi à collégien de 14 ans gabriel
georges et vick était gravement blessé
dans la nuit du 25 au 26 mai soupçonné
d'un vol de scooter arrêté près de la
nationale 3 son visage est maintenant
enfoncé la paroisse orbitre air
orbitaire brisé
mais quel type d'homme avec ou sans
uniforme peut ainsi frappé délibérément
au visage à gamins à terre sont sans
défense
une simple chute pour les policiers mais
n'est ce pas plutôt que gabriel est l'un
de ces indésirables
qu'évoque le tout récent rapport du
défenseur des droits que j'ai d'ailleurs
saisi gabriel est membre d'une
communauté dont l'un de vos
prédécesseurs
n'hésitez pas à dire qu'elle n'avait pas
vocation à s'intégrer dans notre pays
pourtant gabriel c'est aujourd'hui le
visage d'une certaine france le visage
d'une république de meaux quartier une
république abîmées défiguré et
qu'aujourd'hui même vous empêcher de
manifester pour réclamer justice parce
que votre d'autres devises ne devrait
pas être liberté égalité impunité la
violence de policières ne peut plus être
réduite à un agrégat de défaillances
individuelles
il faut agir vendredi dernier nous avons
adressé au premier ministre un courrier
proposant une série de mesures en avez
vous pris connaissance envisagez-vous
enfin de vous en inspirer pour revenir à
cette police prêts publics n qui protège
au lieu d'effrayer une police garante de
la paix sociale merci mme les buts et
les pales et à monsieur christophe
castaner ministre de l'intérieur merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés madame la députée saygin
rubin aux états unis un homme est mort
provoquant une vague d'indignation et de
colère dans le pays et bien au delà
vous l'avez souligné je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire sur la situation
américaine jeu en revanche un
commentaire simple affaire sans appel
sur la situation générale le racisme et
la haine n'ont pas leur place dans notre
société
le racisme divise
le racisme brut ne criez pas à madame la
députée je prends que jusque là vous
n'avez pas de désaccord avec mon propos
le racisme divise leur affiche oppose et
le racisme tu oui madame la députée et
il y a une police une police
républicaine qui protège dans ce pays
les femmes et les hommes de tout y
compris du racisme il ya une police
républicaine qui est engagée jour et
nuit pour la sécurité de nos concitoyens
alors je peux le dire madame la députée
nous combattons nous combattons le
racisme avec force et nous le faisons
sur tous les fronts chaque fois que
c'est nécessaire un plan de lutte
nationale contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme continue à se mettre en
place
j'étais vendredi à marseille où nous
expérimentons un réseau d'enquêteurs
spécialisés sur ce sujet la plateforme
pharos la loi la proposition de loi dit
laeticia via contre les propos divers et
variés qui alimente la machine du
racisme sont autant de sujets sur lequel
nous devons nous mobiliser
nous avons mis en place dans chaque
département un référent et dans chaque
groupement un référent contre le racisme
dans chaque structure départementale ce
combat est au coeur de ce que nous
faisons et dans la formation madame la
députée c'est un sujet majeur nous
travaillons avec l'adil cra nous avons
associé la licra pour faire en sorte que
à chaque instant le combat contre le
racisme le combat contre l'antisémitisme
soit au coeur de l'honneur de notre
république et de la police républicaine
merci monsieur le ministre la parole
comme monsieur guillaume gouffier chat
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur ollier du
secrétaire d'état en charge de la
fonction publique monsieur le ministre
alors qu'aujourd'hui les françaises et
les français retrouvent chaque jour un
peu de leur vie d'avant je tiens à
saluer le travail qui est accompli
depuis le début de la crise que nous
vivons par l'ensemble des agents de la
fonction publique bien entendu je pense
à nos agents de la fonction publique
hospitalière mais je pense aussi à nos
agents de la fonction publique d'état et
à nos agents de la fonction publique
territoriale qui n'ont de cesse
d'oeuvrer au quotidien bon
fonctionnement de nos services publics
durant cette crise
et à la cohésion de notre société de
notre territoire
il y a un peu plus un peu moins d'un an
le 6 août 2019 la loi de transformation
de la fonction publique que vous portiez
monsieur le ministre a été promulguée
l'amélioration est plus difficle sion du
dialogue social avec la mise en place
des comités sociaux réforme des
commissions administratives paritaires
création des contrats de projets
extension des possibilités de
recrutement contractuel instauration
d'une prime de précarité renforcement du
cadre déontologique renforcement de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
et je pourrais continuer toutes ces
mesures font de cette loi une loi
majeure du quinquennat mais aussi un
socle primordial pour remplir son
ambition moderniser la fonction publique
donner plus de souplesse dans la gestion
des ressources humaines et garantir un
meilleur service public à destination
des usagers
à n'en pas douter ces deux voies a su
apporter des outils nécessaires à nos
agents de la fonction publique et aux
employeurs publics durant la crise que
nous connaissons un fonds de faire face
au mieux durant cette crise
les décrets pris d'ailleurs ces
dernières semaines pour faciliter le
recours au télétravail ou bien encore
pour développer le forfait mobilité y
contribuer j'en suis certain aussi
monsieur monsieur monsieur le ministre
l'importance de cette loi n'est plus à
démontrer et sa mise en place est
capital aussi pourriez-vous nous dire où
en êtes vous dans sa mise en place et
quelles sont les prochaines étapes jour
merci merci chers collègues la parole
comme suit olivet du soap secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'action
avec le public
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
gouffier chat vous l'avais dit il ya un
an l'assemblée nationale adopté en
première lecture la loi transformation
la fonction publique il y a quelques
mois elle était promulguée le 6 août
vous avez été pour beaucoup tant dans
son adoption que dans l'adoption des
conclusions par la commission mixte
paritaire qui a permis à cette loi
d'être adopté par les deux assemblées
dans un véritable consensus
beaucoup a été fait depuis pour sa mise
en oeuvre tour qui sont la mobilité la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
avec par exemple l'extension secteur
public de la procédure de rupture
conventionnelle pour simplifier le
dialogue social et le concentré sur
l'essentiel des sujets pour faire en
sorte aussi de donner aux chefs de
service de plus grandes facilités une
plus grande réactivité sur le
recrutement
mais au-delà de ces trois piliers de la
loi d'autres sujets ont été abordés ont
fait l'objet de décrets d'application
je pense à tout ce qui relève de la
question de la formation je pense à ce
qui relève du télétravail est ce que
vous avez adopté il ya un an s'est
avérée particulièrement important
puisque vous aviez prévu la possibilité
d'une crise de l'impossibilité d'accéder
à des bâtiments pour faciliter le
recours à un télétravail de crise
beaucoup plus adapté au régime de droit
commun
je pense évidemment à toutes les
dispositions en matière d'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes puisque celles ci ont été
entièrement mises en oeuvre à l'heure où
nous parlons ou encore dispositions sur
la question de la place des agents
publics reconnus travailleurs handicapés
dans nos services les capacités que nous
avons à leur donner des perspectives de
développement de carrière et de
pérennisation leurs engagements beaucoup
reste à faire et nous avons aujourd'hui
pris 80% des textes d'application de
cette loi adoptée il ya un an nous avons
dans les prochaines semaines a continué
à travailler avec vous toutes et tous
sur un certain nombre d'ordonnancés et
de décrets pour mettre en place une
protection sociale complémentaire pour
mettre en place un plan santé au travail
sur les instructions du premier ministre
pour faire en sorte que la question de
la formation soit revu dans la formation
de la haute fonction publique que
l'accès à des droits renforcés à la
formation pour les agents les plus
fragiles ou encore pour aller encore
plus loin en matière de déconcentration
et de rapprochement de la décision du
terrain d'ici le mois d'octobre
l'ensemble de ces textes décrets
ordonnances et compris sur la prime de
précarité vous seront tous présents
merci monsieur mustapha jaussaud merci
monsieur le président chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et de la
lutte contre les discriminations alors
que nous entamons aujourd'hui la
deuxième phase de déconfinement les
portes qui s'ouvrent sur des quotidiens
confinés pendant huit semaines laisse
apparaître la dure réalité de huit clos
qui ont exacerbé les tensions intra
familiales je vous avais d'ailleurs
alerté par courrier dès le 20 mars 2020
les plaintes pour violences conjugales
ont augmenté de 36%
certes le gouvernement a mis en place
des dispositions supplémentaires comme
la multiplication des points de contact
pour signaler ces actes lâches
inacceptable et intolérable
j'ai moi même au sein de ma
circonscription et oeuvrer au
renforcement de l'information dans
les commerces cette solidarité citoyenne
doit s'inscrire dans un réseau d'actions
structurées et adapté tant en termes de
compétences que de maillage territorial
et de moyens humains et financiers
dans la continuité des mesures déjà
prises
nous voyons apparaître au sein de
certains commissariats des groupes
d'enquêteurs exclusivement dédié aux
affaires de violences conjugales
ce sera ainsi prochainement le cas au
commissariat central de nantes et je
m'en réjouis car la qualité d'écouté et
la réactivité sont essentielles aussi
pouvez vous nous indiquer si la mise en
place de ce type d' équipe va continuer
de se développer à travers la france
tant en zone urbaine que rurale selon
quel calendrier avec quels moyens et
quel suivi le déconfit n'en étant aussi
une période particulièrement risquée en
raison des séparations qui peuvent être
engagées pouvez vous nous dire comment
vous comptez prévenir une augmentation
de violences intrafamiliales
dans ce contexte notamment en terme
d'hébergement je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole et à
monsieur christophe castaner ministre de
l'intérieur merci monsieur le président
mesdames sur l'équité madame la députée
le sujet que vous abordez d'un sujet
essentiel qui nous mobilise toute la
lutte contre les violences conjugales
tout comme la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales doit être une priorité
de chacune et chacun d'entre nous et
n'ayez pas de doute c'est une priorité
du gouvernement est de forces de
sécurité intérieure dans le cadre du
confinement vous l'avez dit notre
volonté était d'ouvrir le plus largement
possible tous les moyens de donner
l'alertent parce que nous savions que le
confinement pouvait être l'empêchement
l'empêchement de donner l'alerté donc je
ne vais pas revenir sur tous les
dispositifs mais la montée en puissance
de la plate forme de signalement que
nous avons installé il ya un peu plus
d'un an qui travaillent 24 heures sur 24
7 jours sur 7
l'élargissement des plages horaires du
39 19 et renforcement des moyens la mise
en place du dispositif de signalement
par sms au 114 dans l'hypothèse où
quelqu'un ne peut pas téléphoner ne peut
pas chatter sur la plateforme nous
voulions qu'elle est cette possibilité
mais aussi les points de présence dans
des centres commerciaux comme les
pharmacies qui ont parfaitement joué le
jeu à chaque fois que cela était
nécessaire
autant d'occasions de nous donner les
moyens de d'accompagner l'alertent et
d'empêcher la violence
vous l'avez rappelé des moyens
exceptionnels ont des mises en place
aussi sur l'hébergement près d'un
million d'euros ont été dégagés par le
secrétariat d'état en charge de ces
questions là pour des pour financer 20
mille nuitées supplémentaires pour que
là aussi et de l'instruction était très
claire donnée au préfet en aucun cas on
ne puisse imaginer que pour des raisons
matérielles
une femme ou un membre de la famille ne
soient pas protégés nous sommes
mobilisés sur ce sujet nous attendions
madame la députée à une explosion des
chiffres poste confinement et je ne
partage pas votre indicateur il faudra
qu'on regarde cela sur le + 36 %
parce que si je regarde sur la période
du 11 au 24 mai plus de 1600 750
victimes de violences conjugales sont
venus porter plainte c'est énorme mais
c'est moins que la période de référence
identique à l'année dernière
dans tous les cas c'est trop et il nous
faut comme vous l'avez dit inscrire
notre travail dans la durée
former nos agents à cela et faire en
sorte que dans chaque commissariat dans
chaque brigade il y 'a minima' une
personne spécialement formés pour lutter
contre les violences intrafamiliales et
les violences sexuelles
merci monsieur le ministre la parole de
monsieur thierry michel
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'état chargé des
personnes handicapées
madame la ministre il ya plus de trois
semaines les élèves ont commencé à
reprendre le chemin de l'école étape
fondamentale après deux mois de
confinement
à cet égard je remercie le gouvernement
d'avoir pris en compte les besoins de
plus de 360 milles enfants en situation
de handicap
ce que la risée par l'éducation
nationale est désigné à juste titre
comme publics prioritaires
le confinement les a lourdement impacté
malgré l'engagement exceptionnel de
l'ensemble des acteurs que je tiens ici
à saluer en effet partout sur le
territoire des initiatives innovantes
ont fleuri pour pallier la fermeture des
écoles et combiner les efforts des
associations et enseignants dans
l'intérêt de l'enfant
à ce titre madame la ministre avez vous
pu repérer grâce à la plate forme
solidaire handicap lancé avec le cncph
des bonnes pratiques et des actions
positives qu'il serait bon de voir
perdurer dans le temps
pouvez vous nous faire part d adaptation
réussie pour dépasser les difficultés
causées par le confinement
par ailleurs je suis attaché comme tout
le monde ici à l'école inclusive
celle ci passe par la formation des
enseignants est essentielle et
l'accompagnement des élèves et des
familles les nouveaux pôles inclusif
d'accompagnement localiser déployer
jusqu'en 2022 en sont un levier
essentiel
il s'agit de reconnaître le rôle
fondamental des accompagnants d'enfants
en situation de handicap encore plus
sollicité en ces temps difficiles
ainsi après trois semaines de reprise
progressive pouvez vous madame la
ministre nous livrer un point de la
situation des élèves en situation de
handicap et de leurs accompagnants
quels enseignements avez vous identifié
pour préparer au mieux la reprise plus
large des cours et en septembre
une rentrée scolaire respectueuse de la
promesse d'un accompagnement
personnalisé de chaque enfant en
situation de handicap
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole à madame sophie cluzel
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le député monsieur le député
thierry michel merci pour votre question
qui me permet à mon tour de sérieux et
l'engagement des enseignants et des
professionnels du médico social auprès
des familles et de leurs enfants
je visitais vendredi dernier lauréat
l'ensemble scolaire de toulouse lautrec
et puis vraiment mesurer l'engagement de
cette épice équipe mixte et du question
nationale médico-social qui a su
justement accompagner et dans le soin et
dans les apprentissages les enfants en
situation de handicap
le confinement été une épreuve pour les
familles monoparentales surtout elles
ont dû à la fois s'adapter à la
continuité pédagogique être rééducateurs
parfois elle même gérée l'amplification
des troubles et je voudrais saluer aussi
les aidants familiaux qui ont été une
vraie force pendant ce confinement
nous avons pris plusieurs mesures pour
les accompagner nous avons prorogé leurs
droits immédiatement des dérogations
pour faciliter les sorties des
interventions médico-social à domicile
des sauts des offres de répit et de re
dégage pour autant il nous faut encore
les accompagner alors la structuration
de 510 initiative citoyenne sur la plate
forme solidaire handicap que je tiens à
saluer 98% vont perdurer
il ya eu plus de soixante quatorze mille
visiteurs c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle avec jean-michel bancaire nous
avons fait du retour des élèves en
situation de handicap à l'école une
priorité elle a été réaffirmée dans
notre dos
nationale et nous avons réuni ensemble
l'ensemble des recteurs et des dg de rs
pour confirmer cette priorité le rôle
déterminant des accompagnons d'élèves en
situation de handicap pour
l'appropriation des gestes barrière a
été également préciser le fonctionnement
en pole inclusif d'accompagnement
localisé est ici d'une grande utilité
pour vous justement répartir les moyens
et les ressources la semaine dernière 80
% des unités localisées pour l'inclusion
scolaire les ulis était avait reprise et
nous serons à 100 % la semaine prochaine
cette période inédite est un véritable
accélérateur de pratiques que nous
allons consolider ma classe virtuelle du
cned adapté pour les enfants sourds cap
école inclusive et bien d'autres mi juin
nous réunissons le comité national de
suivi d' école inclusive sera réunie en
présence de parlementaires pour
organiser cette rentrée de façon
inclusive et la parole josy pouyeto la
parole merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse c'est un monsieur le
ministre des transports conséquences de
la pandémie du courant un virus le choc
économique en cours est immense la
france la relance est engagé et le
gouvernement a pris et prendra encore à
juste titre des mesures ambitieuses pour
l'inst emule et notre pays a également
besoin de confiance c'est un levier
majeur en de telles circonstances il est
important d'assurer la totale de
circulation des biens et des personnes
si l'on veut relever le défi économique
partout en france
force est de constater que des régions
pourrait souffrir d'une nouvelle forme
d'enclavement je pense à des territoires
très éloignés de paris où le train et
l'avion ne répondent pas aux attentes
c'est le cas dans ma circonscription
d'impôt nous y accueillons deux grandes
entreprises de l'énergie comme total
goûter reggae mais aussi celle de
filière aéronautique agroalimentaire
comme safran gagne euralis ou bien sûr
encore comme celle du bassin industriel
de lacq des milliers d'emplois en
dépendent directement et indirectement
les équipes ont toujours besoin de se
déplacer car les outils de télétravail
ne font pas tout paris reste un point de
passage obligé au départ de pau il faut
parfois sept heures de trêve pour y
arriver
s'ajoutent les faibles projections de
trafic aériennes contre toute attente
avec ce début de reprise
air france n'annonce pas une hausse du
nombre de ses rotations entre pau et
paris mais seulement deux vols par
semaine à rien de partir du 15 juin
avant la crise la compagnie en assurer
une dizaine au quotidien c'est un très
mauvais signal adressé aux acteurs
économiques
j'associe à mon inquiétude du jour celle
des parlementaires berné avec lesquels
nous allons nous avons alerté le
gouvernement
dans un courrier commun daté du 5 mai et
du maire de pau françois bayrou alors
que l'état participe au capital d'air
france que comptez vous entreprendre
monsieur le ministre pour améliorer les
cadences pour que ne s'ajoutent pas à la
crise conjoncturelle des tensions
d'ordre structurel
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean baptiste
jebbari celle de terres d'état chargé
des transports
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
merci pour cette question qui me permet
plus largement de faire un point d'étape
sur la stratégie de déconfinement dans
les transports dont la deuxième phase
débute aujourd'hui
je tiens à rappeler que la première
phase avait pour objectif de permettre
tous les déplacements nécessaires et
dans ce but nous avions travaillé a très
fortement augmenté l'offre tout en
maintenant un niveau de fréquentation
contrôler notamment vous l'avez rappelé
grâce à l'organisation du télétravail et
encore grâce à la mise en place de
filtres ces filtres ont permis une bonne
application des règles sanitaires
notamment du port du masque respecter
dès le premier jour à 95%
nous entamons aujourd'hui une deuxième
phase qui nous permet dans la mesure où
la situation épidémiologique permet
d'augmenter à nouveau l'offre très
significativement ainsi dès aujourd'hui
100 % des sièges sont disponibles et
nous envisageons nous visons une
circulation de 100% des trains d'ici à
la mi juin
par ailleurs avec la suppression de la
règle des 100 km certaines lignes
intérieures essentiel le territoire vous
l'avez site et peuvent reprendre de
façon progressive et contrôlée et
organiser la réouverture de l'aéroport
d'orly étant prévu vous savez pour le 26
juin concernant plus spécifiquement la
desserte de pau sujet
que vous avez évoquées et au sujet
duquel j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec françois bayrou l'aéroport de pau
devrait rouvrir le 15 juin
vous savez que les vols actuellement
programmé correspondent à la demande
anticipée
environ 15 à 25% des taux de remplissage
est dans un premier temps vous l'avez
dit ce sont dix vols hebdomadaires qui
sont prévus pour pau je précise que
c'est une reprise similaire à celle qui
ce qui s'exerce ou qui s'observe dans
les villes de brest ou encore de
montpellier pour les trains de liaison
pour paris sont aujourd'hui opérer la
desserte reviendra à 4 allers retours
quotidiens d'ici à la mi juin soit les
assurés madame la députée que ce
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
pour que le décret flamand se fasse de
façon harmonieuse partout dans le
territoire
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur patrice
verchère merci monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
c'est avec une certaine émotion mais
sans regret que je m'adresse à vous
puisqu'il s'agit de ma dernière question
en tant que député mandat que j'exerce
depuis 2007 j'ai en effet été réélu
maire de la commune nouvelle de cours
que j'avais dû quitter avec regret en
raison du cumul des mandats
si cher monsieur darmanin ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires
même la ministre vous n'ignorez pas le
formidable engagement de toutes les
collectivités dans cette crise sanitaire
les communes les intercommunalités les
départements les régions se sont montrés
à la hauteur de l'urgence dès le premier
jour en assurant et en distribuant leurs
commandes d'équipements de protection
individuelle et en mettant tous leurs
moyens au service de leurs administrés
leur rôle a été précieux et je tiens à
saluer les élus de ces collectivités
cela a d'ailleurs probablement contribué
à atténuer la colère de nos compatriotes
envers les manquements et les carences
manifestes de l'état au début de la
crise sanitaire
mais madame le ministre le plan daide de
4 5 milliards annoncés le 29 mai est
bien loin de lever les inquiétudes les
régions en sont d'emblée exclu ce qui a
suscité leur incompréhension
si ce n'est leur colère pour les
collectivités concernées les recettes
fiscales et domanial sont loin d'être
totalement couverte tandis que les
recettes non tarifaires ne sont pas
compensés la crise génère et va générer
beaucoup plus de dépenses pour les
collectifs
tu es qui ont en charge la politique
sociale comme les départements et les
communes
même la ministre ce plan daide constitue
juste juste un premier pas car il n'est
pas à la hauteur de l'urgence que nous
impose cette crise sanitaire et
économique estimée à plus de 7 milliards
les pertes des collectivités doivent
être intégralement compensé en effet
elles sont déjà et le seront encore plus
demain au corps de la relance économique
avec la commande publique et le soutien
via les régions aux acteurs économiques
des territoires
même la ministre quand le gouvernement
va-t-il présenter un plan daide à
l'ensemble des collectivités à la
hauteur des enjeux
merci de bien vouloir rassurer les élus
locaux merci chers collègues
tous deux vous toulouse veut vous
accompagne dans les mandats que vous
avez choisi d'exercer désormais la
parole est à madame jacqueline go
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec des collectivités
territoriales monsieur le député patrice
verchère
je tiens tout d'abord à vous exprimer
mes félicitations pour votre élection en
tant que maire de la commune de cours
vous avez rappelé que c'était une
commune nouvelle que vous avez souhaité
donc dans le département du rhône
vous avez fait le choix de privilégier
votre mandat de maire je mesure ce que
cela implique bien sûr après vos trois
mandats nationaux mais je sais aussi
pour avoir été maire combien vous aurez
de satisfaction de retrouver pour vous
le terrain de retrouver en proximité vos
concitoyens alors encore une fois mes
félicitations pour votre élection et
pour votre choix
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
je crois que il a été prouvé que les
collectivités territoriales et l'état
devaient travailler ensemble
c'est une conviction que j'ai chevillée
au corps et tous les jours je travaille
dans ce sens je pense qu'il est
dangereux d'opposer l'état et les
collectivités territoriales et je pense
que
le symbole qui a été mis en avant
pendant cette crise notamment les maires
plus les préfets pour trouver des
solutions à la crise a été tout à fait
révélateur
maintenant nous va mais parler des
mesures financières qui ont été
annoncées par le premier ministre après
le travail du député que je salue bien
sûr jean rené cazeneuve le président de
la délégation collectivités
territoriales qui avait reçu mandat du
premier ministre ce ces décisions sont
très importantes
monsieur le député les communes et les
intercommunalités bénéficieront d'une
clause de sauvegarde sur leurs recettes
fiscales et domanial intégra blement
intégra lement pardon financé par l'état
jamais un gouvernement n'a accordé aux
mères une garantie aussi complète mais
c'est pas possible je suis j'ai rien dit
si il est plaisant de vous écouter
je contrôle je parle lentement
mais madame la ministre c'est votre
hommage passionné à monsieur merchet
médias pris tout notre temps parole
merci pour le député qui pensent ça
dernière question vous voulez bien me
faire une exception a raison jamais
jamais il ya lui effectivement de temps
fait pour les communes deuxièmement le
département vous savez que nous allons
répondre à leurs demandes
et je précise pour que les régions et
aussi satisfaction nous avons commencé
des discussions avec les régions et nous
allons signer en juin avec les régions
un projet de partenariat à la fois
répondant aux problèmes financiers des
régions est doublée d'un investissement
notamment dans le cadre de la
préparation des contrats de plan état
région
donc toutes les collectivités locales
seront garantis dans leurs ressources
financières
merci madame la ministre vous avez été
gâté monsieur verchères la parole à
monsieur pire à la raf en pour rester
vous merci beaucoup mon très cher
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues dans la même semaine
notre humanité a été capable d'envoyer
des hommes défier la gravité dans
l'espace pendant que d'autres moins
chanceux en subissez une autre de
gravité beaucoup plus sombre beaucoup
plus dévastatrice c'est celle du racisme
qu'il soit visible ou invisible le
racisme tue mais il n'est pas le seul
l'antisémitisme l'homophobie
l'indifférence tue encore et encore
comment accepter au 21ème siècle que des
femmes et des hommes puissent mourir
sous les coups de créatures humaines
habité par la haine et je ne peux pas
croire ici en ces lieux qu'un homme
n'est raciste mais malheureusement
l'histoire nous démontre qu'il peut le
devenir
le racisme ça s'attaque à la racine il
ne se fraye un chemin là où les
conditions ne sont pas réunies pour
apprendre à connaître l'autre là où
l'égalité des chances d'égalité d'accès
au logement au travail
aux responsabilités et à la dignité ne
sont que des concepts ne baissons jamais
la garde et battons-nous pour que chaque
instance de décision de ce pays
ressemble à une france miniature afin
que l'organisation des richesses
humaines soient guidés par le métissage
des idées des parcours et des cultures
monsieur le premier ministre
pouvez vous nous rappeler ce que le
gouvernement met en oeuvre pour lutter
contre le racisme et pour respecter
l'objectif de développement durable
numéro 16 qui vise à promouvoir
l'avènement de sociétés pacifiques est
ouverte car là où les dealers d'émotion
cultive la haine
la france elle se doit de cultiver
l'excellence
cette excellence qui n'a pas de couleur
pas de genre pas de critères physiques
ni de classe sociale et de préférence
sexuelle ou religieuse je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice monsieur les
députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le président monsieur
le député votre question s'inscrit dans
un contexte de tensions aux états unis
après la mort de georges floyd qui nous
a tous beaucoup choqué la france a
toujours été à l'avant garde de la lutte
contre la haine et contre l'intolérance
mais des événements inacceptable qui
sont survenus ces dernières années nous
ont conduits à réagir et c'est la raison
pour laquelle christophe castaner leur
rappeler tout à l'heure notre
gouvernement a adopté en mars 2018 un
plan national de lutte contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme
et avec ce plan nous souhaitons défendre
la république est également défendre nos
concitoyens plusieurs actions sont mises
en oeuvre dans ce cadre notamment dans
le domaine de l'éducation où jean michel
blanquer a promu une équipe nationale
qui vient appuyer les enseignants
confrontés à ce type de problème
également des exemples et des
innovations forte dans le domaine de
l'amélioration de l'accueil des victimes
ainsi que du traitement de leur plainte
avec la formation des policiers des
magistrats des innovations en lien avec
la méthode de propagation
sur de la haine sur internet et vous
avez voté en ce sens une loi il ya
quelques jours et surtout des sanctions
fortes des sanctions parce que aucun
aucune parole
aucun acte ne peut demeurer sans réponse
l'indifférence n'est pas ici une réponse
et chaque année ce sont 400 à 500
condamnation qui sont prononcées par les
tribunaux à l'encontre de l'adapt
raciste ou antisémite mais les modalités
de propagation de ces de ces crimes de
ces injures évolué et c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'assemblée nationale a
proposé une mission d'information
donc alors caroline abadie sera
rapporteur le gouvernement sera au
soutien
soyez certains que le racisme n'a pas sa
place dans notre république et avec vous
le gouvernement le dira aux efforts et
continuera à agir pour l'éradiquer merci
madame la ministre
la parole devant la marie george buffet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse la crise
sanitaire économique et social touche
tous nos compatriotes
mais je souhaite vous interpeller sur la
situation des jeunes avant le
confinement les chiffres étaient déjà a
rarement 21 % des jeunes entre 18 et 22
ans vivaient sous le seuil de pauvreté
depuis le plus finement a provoqué le
non renouvellement des cdd et la
disparition de job étudiant leur entrée
sur le marché du travail est de plus
très compromise par la crise actuelle
face à cette situation organisation de
jeunesse universitaire et élus de tous
bords appellent à l'extension du rsa aux
moins de 25 ans il est en effet
incompréhensible catégorie d'âge la plus
frappée par la pauvreté
celle dont le taux de chômage est le
plus élevé ne puissent pas bénéficier de
ce minimum social
le rsa n'est évidemment pas un horizon
souhaitable ni pour les jeunes ni pour
le reste de la population mais il est un
filet de survie dont nul ne devrait être
exclues s'il se trouve en situation de
précarité des 18 ans les jeunes peuvent
voter cotiser
rien ne justifie lorsque le travail fait
défaut de les exclure d'un tel
dispositif en complémentarité le groupe
gdr soumettra aux votes de notre
assemblée le 18 juin prochain une
proposition de résolution invitant le
gouvernement
à engager la mise en place d' art venu
étudiants les aides actuelles ne
répondent pas aux besoins des étudiants
la réalité est connu 30% des étudiants
renoncent à des soins médicaux 31% ne
reçoivent pas l'aide de leurs parents
les aides ponctuelles mise à en place
lors de cette crise si elle pallie à
l'urgence haute inapte à régler le
problème de fond aussi monsieur le
secrétaire d'état ma question est double
allez-vous étant le rsa aux moins de 25
ans le gouvernement est il prêt à
s'engager avec nous à la mise en place
d'un revenu étudiants reconnaissant leur
qualité de travailleurs intellectuels
créateurs de richesse dans notre pays
est assis leur permettant de suivre
leurs études dans de meilleures
conditions je vous remercie
merci la parole à monsieur gabriel apple
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
merci à monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés madame la
députée marie-george buffet
je crois qu'il ya un point sur lequel il
n'y a pas de débat entre nous c'est le
fait que nous devons continuer à
accompagner des jeunes et les
accompagner encore davantage alors que
cette crise vient fragiliser leur
insertion dans l'emploi et bien
précarisés des jeunes qui ne l'étaient
pas ou qu'il était déjà mais les
précariser de manière supplémentaire le
débat c'est sur la manière dont nous
souhaitons les accompagner et nous avons
aujourd'hui un lieu de débat sur ce
sujet qui est structurant qui ne
correspond pas immédiatement à la crise
actuelle mais qui est un débat ancien
sur lequel nous avons choisi de nous
atteler c'est le débat sur le revenu
universel d'activité qui évidemment se
poursuivre et moi je suis totalement
prêt à regarder toutes les propositions
que vous pourrez faire dans ce cadre et
puis il ya la question de la réponse
urgente à la crise actuelle pour
accompagner les jeunes parce que oui
vous l'avez dit nous avons des
inquiétudes pour les jeunes nous avons
des inquiétudes pour les jeunes les plus
éloignés je pense aux jeunes en
situation de handicap aux jeunes nitze
comme on les appelle qui sont les plus
éloignés de la formation et de l'emploi
nous avons des inquiétudes pour les
jeunes étudiants qui avaient l'habitude
d'avoir un emploi saisonnier l'été pour
financer une partie de leurs études
le reste de l'année qui auront du mal à
en trouver un cette année et ce à quoi
nous travaillons avec jean michel
blanquer air avec moi yelp et nico avec
bruno le maire c'est un plan global pour
accompagner les jeunes dans cette crise
économique qui sera présenté avant l'été
plusieurs pistes sont déjà sur la table
évidemment maintenant
hier le notre implication sur la
question de la formation et de
l'apprentissage des mesures pourraient
être annoncées dès ce jeudi avec muriel
pénicaud évidemment soutenir l'entrée
dans l'emploi pour les jeunes diplômés
des mesures vont être présentés aussi en
ce sens et puis accompagner
financièrement les jeunes qui sont dans
la précarité qui peuvent avoir un coup
dur d'une situation de rupture et pour
ça ma conviction c'est que nous avons un
très bel outil qui est celui de la
garantie jeunes qui a fait ses preuves
parce qu'il permet d'accompagner
financièrement les jeunes et en même
temps de leur apporter un accompagnement
humain un accompagnement vers
l'insertion et vers la formation et je
crois que nous pouvons regarder vers une
extension massive de la 40e' jeunes pour
répondre à ces situations en tout cas je
suis très ouvert pour en débattre avec
vous ultérieur mans merci monsieur le
ministre la séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance est
suspendue pour cinq minutes